So da bin ich, wusste grad nochmal aus Klo, dem Moment wo ich auf stream starten gedrückt
hab, hab ich mir gedacht irgendwie, war es keine gute Idee, ich soll vielleicht ne Minute
später starten, naja egal, ahja, was macht eigentlich, fällt mir jetzt gerade rein, was
macht eigentlich das 49 Euro Ticket, kommt das jetzt eigentlich demnächst oder lecke
ich critical information, ich glaube ich lecke critical information oder, das Deutschland
Ticket kommt, so ist das so, das sollte ja eigentlich schon fast da sein ursprünglich,
so ja und jetzt, warum das 49 Euro Ticket teurer wird als geplant, naja gut, ist die irgendwas
auf die Reihe kriegen, hab ich ja auch schon gar keine Erwartung mehr dran, ok also steht
das wohl noch mit 1. Mai, na da bin ich mal gespannt, jetzt registrieren, naja mal gucken,
mal gucken, ich werde es auf jeden Fall ausprobieren sobald es am Start ist, das kommt dann mit
dem Deutschen, ganz ehrlich, das hab ich überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt, also ich hab das heut in
den, in den News gelesen, das mit dem Deutschland Takt, dass sie das verschoben haben einfach
mal um 40 Jahre, aber ich hab da von vorher nie was gehört, ach Chico, was ist das, Moment,
ok wieder am Start, die wollte gerade die Tür aufgemacht kriegen, was wollte ich gerade
sagen, genau das hab ich gar nicht mitgekriegt, das hab ich heute erst in den News gelesen,
also keine Ahnung, was da so groß bekannt war das ja im Vorfeld nicht, der anderen Seite,
ich weiß gar nicht, also ich hab's nur am Rande gelesen, aber es ist doch bei Verbesserungen,
was Bahn angeht, es ist doch nicht irgendwie so, so irgendwie so ein Stichtag, davor ist
alles schlecht, danach ist alles gut, das ist doch eher so ne kontinuierliche Sache, weil
wenn man irgendwas auf 2070 legt, heißt das 2069 verschiebt man's wieder, weil man nix
gemacht hat in der Zwischenzeit, außerdem was interessiert die Leute 2070 man, da bin
ich 18, ne, ja doch, ne, Moment, Moment, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, das stimmt überhaupt
nicht, das sind noch 47, ne, doch, 47 Jahre, da bin ich 87, nein ich kann's, 86 bin ich
dann, was interessiert mich wenn ich 86 bin, ob der Deutschlandtakt kommt, bis dahin ist
die Welt, jetzt mal ohne Scheiß Leute, 2070 ist die Welt schon wieder komplett ne andere,
das kann's doch damit überhaupt nicht, also jemand der irgendwas plant für 2070 das ist
doch komplett unseriös, die meisten Leute können nicht wissen, die wissen nicht was
in zwei Jahren ist, geschweige denn in 47, naja, ich weiß nicht, wie kann man denn das
49 Euro Ticket kaufen, ich hab mich damit überhaupt nicht beschäftigt, na gut, PayPal
wahrscheinlich nicht, das ist zu, äh, das kriegen sie nicht hin, ich will jetzt nicht
drauf wetten, dass man da mit PayPal bezahlen kann, Nemo's sind am Start, das ist zu modern
und digital, ne, das glaub ich nicht, dass das funktioniert, da kannst du wahrscheinlich
nur mit dem neuen Personalausweis mit diesem PIN-Code bezahlen dann, Leute, ich hab mir
einen neuen Ausweis beantragt und ich hab den jetzt auch schon am Start, da gab's da
so ein Brief dabei mit irgendwelchen komischen PINs und IDs, ich hab's noch nicht mal gelesen,
ich geh davon aus ich werd's eh nie benutzen, vielleicht sollte ich's mir mal durchlesen,
kann man damit tatsächlich ganz coole Sachen machen, kein Plan, wahrscheinlich, aber habt
ihr auch gelesen, das angeblich TikTok, hab ich irgendwo gehört oder gelesen, dass TikTok
in den USA gesperrt werden soll oder irgendwie sowas, das wird doch eh nix, oder, ich hab
irgendwo was gehört oder aufgeschnappt, dass TikTok irgendwie in den USA gesperrt werden
soll, ein großer Verlust für die Menschheit wird's wahrscheinlich nicht sein, aber die
Leute benutzen das doch trotzdem weiter, das ist doch so im Leben von vielen jüngeren
Leuten drinne, ich hab irgendwas mit TikTok, irgendwas mit TikTok hab ich gelesen, dass
da irgendwas gesperrt werden soll in den USA, ach nee, was war da mit USA, ja er hat irgendwie
sowas, genau, das hab ich mit, oder, wollen, nicht müssen, so rum, ja, hier USA verbietet
TikTok auf Regierungshandys, ach auf Regierungshandys würde ich das jetzt auch, warum würde ich
auf Regierungshandys, würde ich immer TikTok installieren, China-Chinese Zeug, ja, was
ist mit den Pyramiden heute, neue Kammer in Pyramide nachgewiesen, aha, gibt's noch
mehr Mumien, die da rumliegen, muss man eigentlich noch den Fingerabdruck, Moment was heißt
noch, man muss das jetzt schon machen und immer noch, jaja, also das wird auch nicht
weggehen, das ist jetzt nicht so wo man sagen muss, ja noch, bald ist es weg, ich musste
meine Fingerabdrücke abgeben für den Ausweis, die natürlich unter strengsten Auflagen gespeichert
werden und nur für Personalausweiszwecke benutzt werden, natürlich, glaube ich, glaube ich
das sofort, aber eins muss ich mal sagen, in Hanau, also ich hab den ja im Bürger, Bürger
Service Hanau beantragt, den Ausweis, die haben das wirklich gut gemacht, normalerweise
bin ich ja immer am flamen, wenn es irgendwie um so Behördengeschichten geht, aber die
haben das wirklich gut gemacht, dann meldest du dich an online und dann kriegst du ne Nummer
wie beim Ikea Support und da kommst du pünktlich hin und du bist innerhalb von 10 Minuten dran,
dann machst du das, du kannst dort am Terminal Fingerabdruck machen, Foto machen, Unterschrift
und sowas, easy, dann wird es gleich da gemacht und zwei Wochen später hast du den Ausweis,
also das haben die wirklich gut gemacht, da kann ich mir nicht beschweren, also das war
das erste Mal, dass mir ein Behördengang nicht auf den Sack gegangen ist, das ging wirklich
gut, ich muss mal kurz in meine Mails gucken, was erchecken, ob da noch was gekommen ist
heute, nope, kam nix, Leute ich hab bei Konunu eine Bewertung abgegeben vor ner Weile und
seitdem ich die Bewertung abgegeben hab, spammen die mich mehrfach in der Woche zu, das ist
neuer, neue Bewertung gibt und neue Newsartikel und so ein Shit, ich will das alles gar nicht
haben, ich wollte einfach nur ne Bewertung abgeben, weil die mich net gefragt haben ob
ich ne Bewertung abgeben kann und jetzt werd ich zugespampt von dem Laden, kann man bestimmt
abbestellen aber warum ist das standardmäßig so, es interessiert mich nicht die Beuyser
und Null, was die für komische Artikel schreiben, Haken setzen, ja wahrscheinlich irgendwo,
weil das überhaupt standardmäßig drin ist, nervt mich, voll auf den Sack, ich drück
mal ein bisschen, ich drück mal ein bisschen R5, ob es irgendwas gibt, was mich anspricht,
die Playlist ist wieder nicht richtig, wie nennt man das, normalisiert, was die Soundlautstärke
angeht, wir machen heute keine Massive Javascript Customizing Action, wir machen heute nichts
großartig, ich bin viel zu kaputt, nein das können wir heute machen, das können wir machen,
das hab ich noch offen, was war das noch mal für ein Video, guck mal ich hab mich wieder
selbst promotet, was war das für ein Video, die bizarre vierte Konsolengeneration, alles
ist ein NFT, das hier meint ihr oder, ja heute wird nicht gehaschelt, wird heute nicht,
ich glaub das war's alles, was soll ich noch irgendwas spannendes ein, Hacker News war
diese Woche auch nichts großartig Interessantes, gibt's schon das erste Problem, noch bevor
ich angefangen hab, kann ich euch auch mal erzählen, gibt's schon das erste Problem,
ich muss da noch ein paar Dokumente hochladen vor dem ersten Arbeitstag und die haben mir
ne Mail geschrieben im Januar, dass ich da jetzt meinen Account anlegen kann, nur dass
dieser Link zum Account anlegen expired ist mittlerweile, aber warum hätt ich das jetzt,
das reicht ja, wenn man das einen Monat vorher macht und da hab ich dat hingeschrieben und
jetzt haben sie irgendwie sinngemäß gesagt, ich soll die Passwort Recovery Funktion benutzen,
wo ich noch nie eingeloggt war und mein Passwort gar nicht recoveren kann, mal gucken ob ich
da morgen ne Antwort krieg, da ich den Kram hochladen kann, also klappt auch nicht alles
ohne Probleme, aber macht ja nix, ja ich freu mich tatsächlich richtig drauf, es hört sich
jetzt vielleicht jetzt so an, ich bin ziemlich kaputt, aber doch ohne Scheiß, ich freu mich
wirklich drauf, ich hab mir sogar seit Ewigkeiten mal wieder, seit Ewigkeiten einen Udemy Kurs
gekauft für 14€ oder so, für Google Kubernetes, weil außer zweimal durchgeklickt im Assistent
hab ich mit Google Kubernetes noch gar nicht so viel gemacht, also was heißt gar nicht
so viel, nix im Endeffekt, ich hab mit dem Assistent den Cluster mal angelegt, das wars,
hab ich mir nen Kurs gekauft zu Google Kubernetes, ich mein im Prinzip, brauchst dir ein bisschen
drumrum, das Handling, vielleicht so ein paar Google Besonderheiten, aber im Prinzip ist
es ein Managed Kubernetes, der Rest ist das gleiche, Lpick 1, das wird mich ernsthaft
interessieren, ich hab nie nen Lpick gemacht, also wie gesagt ich beschäftig mich schon
wirklich lange, lange mit Linux, gibt es irgendwo Übungsfragen oder Test, also Probe-Tests
zum Lpick 1, ich würd gern mal nen Lpick 1 Test machen und gucken ob ich das packen
würde, weil ich mein, nur weil man über 15 Jahre mit Linux täglich arbeitet, wer weiß
was die da fragen, das heißt in der Lage nicht, dass man das alles weiß, hast du ein
MacBook, nee, nee, wie kommst du da drauf, hab kein MacBook, denkst du dass Rust im Bereich
von Embedded Systemen besser ist als C++ und warum, das ist erstmal vollkommen egal ob
es besser oder schlechter ist als C++, die Infrastruktur für Rust im Embedded Bereich
ist oftmals gar nicht wirklich vorhanden, guck dir zum Beispiel ESP32 an als Plattform,
du kannst da drauf nicht sinnvoll entwickeln mit Rust, dir fehlt die Standard Library,
dir fehlt die Compiler, ja es gibt ein paar so Proof of Concept Projekte, aber nix wirklich
Gutes was mit dem offiziellen C++ und dem offiziellen C SDK mithalten kann, also insofern
es ist egal ob es besser wäre, die meisten Embedded Systeme kannst du mit Rust gar nicht
gescheit programmieren, weil dir die ganzen Sachen drum rum fehlen.
Gute Laptops für die Entwicklung empfehlen, tatsächlich kann ich dir nur empfehlen das
was ich selbst jetzt schon im Einsatz hatte, wohlgemerkt nicht selbst gekauft, also da
würde ich wahrscheinlich was anderes benutzen, ich mach das mal auf, gucken wir uns gleich
mal an, also MacBooks sind anscheinend, weil es hier gerade jemand geschrieben hat, MacBooks
sollen wohl wirklich ganz nice sein, gerade für Entwickler, die haben ordentlich Power,
es ist ein Unix-like Unterbau mit halbwegs ordentlichen Oberflächen wenn man das mag,
aber was ich hatte waren bisher ganz viele Lenovo Kisten, also ich betreibe die ja immer
nur mit Linux ja, muss ich dazu sagen, also keine Ahnung wie das mit Windows oder so aussieht,
betreibe die nur mit Linux, also die ganzen Lenovo Kisten die ich die letzten Jahre überhaupt
die waren eigentlich außerhalb bloß alle ziemlich gut zu gebrauchen.
Aktuell habe ich ein Surface Book von Microsoft und lasse Linux drauf laufen, das funktioniert
auch ganz gut, das Problem beim Surface Book ist, die haben so ein paar kleine Inkompatibilitäten
mit Linux, wer hätte das gedacht, zum Beispiel wenn du deine Festplatte voll verschlüsselt
hast und du musst ein Passwort eingeben beim booten, dann ist an der Stelle beispielsweise
der Tastaturtreiber für die Surface Book Tastatur noch nicht geladen, da musst du
immer eine externe Tastatur USB anschließen, dass das funktioniert, also das ist nicht
so geil, insgesamt ist es aber ziemlich problemlos gewesen, ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich hatte
noch nie Probleme, egal mit welchem Notebook wo ich Linux drauf laufen hatte, das ging
eigentlich immer alles ganz gut, früher hattest du oftmals Probleme mit WLAN Adaptern und
sowas und du hast heute auch noch Probleme mit so komischen Grafikkartenlösungen, mit
externer Grafikkarte zum Anschöpseln und sowas, aber ein Notebook zum Arbeiten, das
funktioniert eigentlich alles, wohlgemerkt, ich verwende die Dinger auch nicht mit Akku,
ich benutze die als Arbeitsgerät auf der Arbeit, ziehe die mal vom Akku ab, laufe mal
in irgendeinen Raum oder so, also ich benutze die nicht irgendwie 3-4 Stunden am Akku, also
das kann sein, dass das nicht gut ist, dass man zum Beispiel Linux mehr Akku verbraucht
oder was auch immer, da kann ich nichts zu sagen, ich mache LPG easy im Schlaf, ok wir
machen mal Test, ok Sekunde, wir machen mal kurz Test, eine Runde Testfragen, LPG 1 Poggers,
also LPG actual exam questions, ok das machen wir keine 105, ich bookmarke mir das mal,
das können wir das nächste Mal machen, aber ich will, was ist denn das eigentlich für
eine Seite, ist das legal, ich war dazu ganz sicher, komm wir machen mal 4 Fragen, 4 Fragen
ist doch easy, das sind die ersten, die ersten 4 Fragen, den Rest können wir danach nächstes
mal irgendwie machen, ok which type of file system is created by MKFS when it is executed
with a block level name only and without, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich würde auf X4 tippen,
ich gebe immer MKFS X4 ein, ich persönlich würde auf X4 tippen, allerdings das kann
auch durchaus noch was älteres sein, X2, keine Ahnung, das ist ja immer falsch gelegen,
na gut macht ja auch Sinn, macht ja auch Sinn, es ist MKFS und es ist auch nicht MKFS.X4,
das heißt MKFS ist wahrscheinlich entstanden zu Zeiten von X2, ja da hätte ich eigentlich
drauf kommen können, ok which humask value ensures that new directories can be read, written
and listed by their owning user read and listed by their, also wir brauchen 75, also 750 brauchen
wir, 750 klingt sinnvoll, ach humask values, das habe ich jetzt falsch gelesen, das habe
ich jetzt falsch gelesen, humask ist umgedreht von CHMOD, humask ist genau andersrum, ok
da muss man wirklich genau gucken, da muss man wirklich genau gucken, das kann man nicht
einfach so überfliehen, das ist chibade, das ist eine richtig geile chibade frage,
wisst ihr mal, das stimmt ja was ich gesagt habe, aber humask ist andersrum, was ist denn
das?
Was?
Which of the following commands changes the number of days before the exit, ja das habe
ich schon gemacht, was ist das?
Es ist wahrscheinlich ein Minus oder?
Ein kaputtes Minus, also wenn ich ehrlich bin, gucke ich sowas nach, aber aus dem Kopf
weiß ich es nicht, ich würde, weißt du das liegt am Dark Mode, ich würde aber mal darauf
tippen, dass Tune to FS so alt ist, dass es eventuell nicht Minus Minus Days ist, sondern
Minus N oder C für Count oder Number, es könnte aber auch, ich würde auf C oder N
tippen, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt aus dem Kopf nicht, aber das
ist sowas, das muss man eigentlich auch gar nicht aus dem Kopf wissen, es ist B, es ist
Minus C, keine Ahnung, von wegen ich mache den Lpick mit links, schon mal 3 Fragen direkt
verkackt, zumindest lage ich richtig mit, es ist nicht Minus Minus Days, which is the default
percentage of reserved space for the root user only.
Ist das überhaupt was, ja ist wahrscheinlich, doch doch ist bestimmt was, ehrlich gesagt
ich weiß es nicht, 10% klingt nach einem guten Default aber auch zu viel, deswegen würde
ich sagen 5 oder 3, ich sage jetzt einfach mal 5, hey richtig, Fogu, ach komm, komm eins
machen wir noch, ich bin kein Robot, ich muss jetzt einfach nur klicken, ich bin kein Robot
und dann lässt er mich weitermachen, das ist mal ein Captcha, das finde ich gut, einfach
sagen nein nein ich bin kein Robot und gut ist, jetzt wird es aber jetzt, ist das wirklich
sinnvolles wissen, nein finde ich nicht, alles was man in 30 Sekunden googeln kann oder
mannpage gucken ist nicht wirklich sinnvoll auswendig zu lernen, aber so sind Zertifikate,
so sind Zertifikate, deswegen finde ich die meisten Zertifikate auch unsinnig, ok lass
mal kommen, die 4 Stück machen wir jetzt noch schnell, which of the following is true when
a file system which is neither listed in etcfs tab nor known to the system is mounted manually,
which of the following is true, ok also wenn es nicht in the fs tab steht, auch nicht schon
eingehängt ist wenn ich es vorhand mount ok, ok was haben wir für Auswahl, systemd ignoriert
manuelle mounts, was hat denn mount mit systemd überhaupt zu tun, systemctl, seriously verwendet
irgendjemand systemctl mount, ich hab noch nie jemand gesehen der systemctl mount benutzt,
ich wusste bis jetzt gar nicht dass es systemctl mount überhaupt gibt, keine Ahnung, ich wusste
nicht dass es das überhaupt gibt, aber ich meine es ist systemd, das kann alles ja, anscheinend
kann es das, ok systemctl mount sync, what can be used to create a mount, keine Ahnung,
systemd automatically generates a mount unit, was alles ist systemd mountpoint, was wollen
die von mir, alles ist systemd mountpoint unit is created, systemd unmounts the file
also, hä, tanza danke schon für den sub, was wollen die von mir, which of the follows,
mounted manually, wisst ihr wie mounted manually aussieht, mount def blablub nach slash keckel,
was weiß ich was systemd damit macht, ich reveal jetzt mal diese solution, aha, systemd
automatically generates a mount unit and monitors the mounting point, ist das so, discussion,
ist das so, ok was phil blank, which program updates the database that is used by the locate
command, ja, das weiß ich, das habe ich schon gemacht, aber, update, nee, db, update db
kann das sein, kann es sein, dass es einfach nur update db heißt, update db, update db,
ich, ich tue einfach mal, ich glaube es ist, ich glaube es ist update db, locate, locate
ist ein program, wo du dateien suchen kannst, allerdings vorher einen index erstellst mit
den dateien, da kannst du schneller suchen, da musst du nicht mit find die komplette
plane durchsuchen, so krass mit locate direkt auf den index suchen, ich glaube es ist update
db, ok, update db, nice, update db, immerhin, nochmal, nochmal glück gehabt, nochmal glück
gehabt, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, da haben wir nochmal glück gehabt, was ist das denn, wtf, auf
meinem zweiten monitor, möchte sich, möchte sich skype updateen, skype, geh weg, wtf und
das ist doch nicht mal skype, das ist das echte skype, das ist diese skype windows app, omega
lul, ok, also was haben wir als nächstes, what does the command mount--bind to, ich,
ich glaube, das kopiert, ne das kopiert nicht, kopiert das als fall, das, das, das, das
linkt, das linkt irgendwie einen mount in anderes verzeichnis, weiß ich ob das das
richtig beschrieben habe, aber mal gucken, in welches content, ja, das da, das, das klingt
gut, it mounts all available files, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee,
nee, es muss a sein, das, das passt, easy, das ist ja wenigstens, komm mal fragen wo
ich was zu sagen kann, ok, consider the following output of the ls, nee, immerhin, ls, was,
ls-i, oder soll das, encoding, shit encoding, kaputtes, keck alu encoding, how would a new
file named c.txt be created is the same, i, what, keine ahnung, wann macht man denn so
was, ok, ah, moment, ah, moment, moment, moment, ok, die wollen lm, die wollen ln-optionen,
also ln, normal ist ein einfacher swimlink, und, was so, ist das hier für ne schreibweise,
warte mal, warte mal, wie war das noch, ich, moment, ln ist ein swimlink, eh, ein swimlink
ist quasi nur ne datei, die auf ne andere zeigt, ln, ein hardlink, ist auf filesystem
ebene quasi die gleiche referenz, das heißt, ein hardlink geht ja auch nicht partitionsübergreifend,
das heißt, ich möchte ein hardlink erstellen, oder, verstehe ich die frage richtig, vielleicht
verstehe ich die frage richtig, warte mal, jetzt gucken, wenn ich das jetzt misst erzählt
hab, ja, ja, das triffts im grossen und ganzen, so, problem ist nur, ich hab keine ahnung,
dann ist es ln-h für hardlink, würde ich jetzt einfach mal, ich tippe jetzt einfach
mal auf a, was, ok, vergiss es, keine ahnung, von wegen, ich mach easy nen lp, warum, moment,
warte mal, discuss, ok, csc ist correct, because only ln is used without any option creating
a hardlink, ach, das stimmt ja auch, normalerweise musst du ja auch minus s machen, ja, siehste,
da hätt ich beim tippen wahrscheinlich dran gedacht, aber beim lesen nicht, ja, ja, ja,
natürlich, ln macht ja standardmäßig sogar hardlink, du musst ln-s machen, für den richtigen
zoomlink, tatsächlich, ja, jaja, siehste mal, doch nicht, doch nicht so easy das ganze,
alter, was willst du hier, peter, zw, was ist der unterschied zwischen zoomlink und hardlink,
das hab ich ja grad versucht zu erklären, nen zoomlink ist quasi ne datei, die auf ne
andere datei zeigt, nen zoomlink ist quasi wie ne verknüpfung unter windows, so kann
man sich so ungefähr vorstellen, ja, ein hardlink ist auf filesystem ebene die gleiche referenz,
das heißt das geht auch nicht partitionsübergreifend oder filesystemübergreifend, zoomlink geht
auf partitionssystemübergreifend, filesystemübergreifend, ein hardlink nicht, ja, dafür kannst du zum
beispiel mit, bin grad am überlegen, du kannst mit hardlinks kannst du irgendwie speicherplatz
sparen, sind Sachen damit beschäftigt man sich nicht täglich, aber mit zoomlinks kannst
du auch speicherplatz fahren, wenn man den hardlink löscht, löscht man auch die ursprungsdatei,
da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, ich glaube schon, aber ne, ne, ne, ne, das, das nicht,
das glaub ich nicht, ähm, oder, oder doch, das ist immer, weiß ich aus dem kopf gar
nicht, also es wäre, es wäre natürlich logisch, ich mein wir können es ausprobieren, easy,
wo ist mein zweiter desktop, äh, wir sind ja weg, wir können das, wir können das einfach
ausprobieren, das ist ja einfach, zeigt jeder zoomlink auf ein hardlink, ne, hardlink zeigt
auf dieselbe datei, ja, bei zoomlink löscht du dir den pointer, ja das ist klar, aber
ich weiß nicht, ob du nicht bei einem hardlink, also du musst dir irgendwie auch, du musst
dir beim hardlink auch irgendwie das wieder rückgängig machen können, vielleicht gibt
es ja dann irgendwie einen, äh, klar, extra parameter für rm oder sowas, hier, probieren
wir doch mal aus, mkdir temp, das allerbeste verzeichnis ever, so hier, touch, touch keckel.txt,
so, sehr schön, das wollte ich haben, so, also ln-s, äh, keckel nach blub.txt, ok,
also das ist ein softlink, das ist, ich mach das mit minus s schon ganz anders, das ist
ein softlink, das sieht man auch hier dran, an den rechten und allem, man sieht, dass
es eine eigene datei ist, die da drauf zeigt, so, und jetzt machen wir ln gatchi.txt und
jetzt sieht man, ok, die datei hat die gleichen rechte und sieht exakt so aus, wie, wie die
andere datei, man erkennt auch nicht, dass es ein link ist, ja, ls, so, kann man das
machen, dann sieht man jetzt auch die inode-id, genau, also sprich, das ist auf filesystem
eben eine referenz auf die gleiche datei, du kannst jetzt glaube ich auch gar nicht
mehr so ohne weiteres sagen, ob das ein link davon ist oder das ein link davon, das ist
auf filesystem eben die gleiche referenz, so, wie das jetzt bei em ist, bin ich tatsächlich
so aus dem kopf überfragt, also das hier ist einfach, wenn ich den symlink lösche,
dann ist die ursprüngliche datei noch da, ne, das seht ihr, das löscht ja nur den symlink,
so, bumm, jetzt hatte ich die frage, wenn ich jetzt den, diesen link lösche, dann vermute
ich mal die datei ist tatsächlich wirklich weg, weil es geht ja wirklich filesystem-mäßig,
ne, ah, anscheinend nicht, siehst du mal, em ist schlau, em ist file-fed, em checkt
das wahrscheinlich, dass das ein, dass das ein, ein hardlink ist, ok, siehst du mal,
da lernt man was, da hat es sich doch schon mal gelohnt, dass wir lpq-fragen gemacht
haben, jaja, seht ihr mal, abo-falle, ja danke leute für die subs, ich hab jetzt, ich hab
jetzt einige schon übersehen, indem man, indem man em verwendet wird auf unlink verwiesen,
aha, siehst du mal, das sind so sachen, damit befasst man sich tatsächlich im täglichen
benutzen relativ wenig, weil man es wenig verwendet, aber aus dem gesichtspunkt hat lpq durchaus
seinen sinn, weil das sind so basic sachen, die man aber so vielleicht gar nicht im kopf
hat beziehungsweise sich gar nicht so im detail damit beschäftigt, also muss ich sagen, macht
durchaus sinn sich damit zu beschäftigen, find ich grad halt mal so verkehrt, auswendig
lernen von irgendwelchen mehreren befehlen finde ich allerdings bescheuert, hast du auf
deinem pc dualboot oder ist das windows emuliert, oder wie nutzt du das dann zum zocken, ist
umgedreht, umgedreht, du hast ja gerade gesehen, ich hab windows als hausbetriebssystem und
linux in der vm, so kann ich easy zwischen beiden switchen und ich hab eigentlich fast
keine performance einboosten in der vm, weil das was ich in der vm mach, brauch ja nix
großartiges, cpu technisch ist in der vm zwischen vm und host eh kein großartiger
unterschied und gut gpu krieg ich halt nicht rein, aber brauch ich in der vm ja auch nicht
emacs wim und nano, jetzt gehts aber los hier, wer macht denn emacs noch 2023, ich hab früher
auch mal emacs verwendet, aber ich hab schon jahrelang emacs nicht mal mehr auf gehabt
beziehungsweise gar nicht mehr installiert, kennst du ein gutes 19 zoll serverrack empfehlen,
ich könnte dir das empfehlen was ich hab, das gibt es aber glaub ich nicht mehr, auf
youtube haben die alle dieses komische starlink rack, keine ahnung ob das wirklich was taucht,
die frage die du dir stellen musst ist nicht so sehr, was ist ein gutes rack, sondern welches
rack passt bei dir rein und wie viel geld willst du ausgeben, wenn du es nämlich besonders
billig haben willst, dann nimm den 19 zoll ikea schrank, den 19 zoll ikea tisch, das
ist zwar kein rack, aber dank 19 zoll passt das zoll ich auch gut rein, das ist halt halt
die budget variante, achso er hat schon vorgeschlagen hier, dann musst du gucken wie tief dein raum
also brauchst du volle tiefe oder pass nur 40 cm rein, gachi, bass, habt ihr auf der
arbeit auch so billige tastaturen, nein ich nicht, weil ich hab ne eigene tastatur mit
gebracht, gute mechanische, eine ducky one skyline hab ich auf der arbeit, selbstverständlich
aber mit numblock, dieses teil hier extrem exzellente pogu tastatur, die ist wirklich
sehr nice, sieh genau so aus wie die hier und die kann ich auch wirklich nur empfehlen,
die ist wirklich gut, ich hab unter 2-3 tasten so kleine silikonringe gemacht, das sind
die tasten wo ich immer besonders gerne fest drauf fahr, um irgendwas in befehl abzuschicken
oder so, zum beispiel die enter taste vom numblock, da kloppe ich gerne drauf, da will
ich die leute nicht zu sehr belästigen, deswegen hab ich da so kleine silikonringe drunter
gemacht, aber die kann ich empfehlen, aber ja ansonsten haben wir auch ziemlich billige
schrot tastaturen auf der arbeit, das ist auch der grund warum ich mir auf die arbeit
meine ducky one skyline mitgebracht hab, also eine nicht meine ist es aber das ist nicht
die die ich vorher daheim hatte, die hab ich extra dafür gekauft, eine ducky one skyline
mitgebracht hab und meine alte logitech g502, das ist die mit dem endlos scroll mausrad
und das hat mir auf der arbeit schon oft mal richtig was gebracht dieses mausrad, dieses
endlos scroll mausrad, wenn ihr mal in teams chats was gesucht habt und ihr wisst der chat
ist drei wochen her, dann scrollt ihr erstmal fünf minuten und mit dem maus, weil die teams
suche kannst du ja auch vergessen und mit der g502, das ist eigentlich die optimale
microsoft teams maus, da machst du einmal, schubst du einmal schubst du das scroll mausrad
an und dann scrollt das für eine minute vor sich hin, man könnte natürlich auch irgendein
macro oder so nehmen, aber mausrad, beste, silent red switches, ja ich hab die standard
switches, was sind denn die, was sind die standard switches, braun, braun cherry switches, display
switch, können wir gleich mal angucken, ja die machen aber schon ein bisschen krach
meine switches die ich hab, aber deswegen hab ich unter den tasten wo ich bloß drauf
haue, silikon, silikonringe, umelpimpel, danke schön für den sub,
panzer, huge subscription, 44 monate
leon danke für den sub, ja ebay ohne scheiß, das ist eine wirklich
gute idee, können wir gleich mal kurz gucken, rec neu kaufen würde ich auch nicht machen,
weil recs werden ja nicht wirklich schlechter dadurch das sie gebraucht sind, ja guck mal
mal 19 zoll rec, wobei wie sucht man da nacht am besten, zoll rec vielleicht so rum, ausgeschrieben,
ja guck mal hier, naja moment das sind eher netzwerkschränke, das sind netzwerkschränke,
wir suchen mal das surfer rec, guck mal was wir da finden, 12 hau, surfer rec, ja, ist
auch noch ein offenes, wobei das ist doch kein richtiges rec, was denn das, wobei doch
das ist ein richtiges rec, man sieht das ja mit den schienen, das sieht nur aus ein bisschen
komisch aus, man sieht ja auch nirgends wo du die server reinschrauben kannst, also das
sieht jetzt nicht so nice aus, ja das ist vielleicht ein bisschen, das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen overkill für daheim, so ein kompletter serverschrank, die dinger sind
ja auch übelst tief, das kriegt man meistens eh nicht in den, 200 mal 100, wobei 100, 200
ist die höhe, 100 ist die tiefe wahrscheinlich und 60 ist die breite, weil 60 tiefe wäre,
wie viel ist denn 19 zoll, 19 zoll 2 cm, 48, ja dann ist das hier die breite, 60 mit dem
ganzen Krempel drum herum, da passen fast alle server rein mit 100 tiefe, ja aber so gut
ist es, sehr gut die Idee chat bei ebay zu gucken, ja ich glaube schon, dass das die
standard, die brown switches sind, die ich drinne hab, na ebay, ebay klein anzeigen
kann ich, also ich könnte auf ebay klein anzeigen nix kaufen, weil ebay klein anzeigen
hat mich ja gebannt, obwohl ich nie in ein account bei ebay klein anzeigen hatte wohl
gemerkt und als ich dann gefragt habe, warum die mich gebannt haben, haben sie gesagt wir
bitten sie unsere marktplatz fern zu bleiben, ich hatte nie in ein account bei ebay klein
anzeigen, kack spaß für einen mann, mit dem will ich nix zu tun haben, ich hab euch
ja sogar die support, die antwort, der support, das support, der support laden ist da gezeigt,
also vom support die antwort hab ich auch auf twitter gepostet, ja man kann das einfach
mit jeder x beliebig anderen email adresse machen, klar aber ich seh ich nicht ein, vielleicht
sollte ich mal deine dsgvo auskunft hinschicken, was sie über mich haben, um so ein bisschen
abzufacken noch.
so was stand auch in der wohnung im wohnzimmer drin, wobei in der wohnung stand jetzt nicht
so ein rack, da stand ein storage system im wohnzimmer auf dem teppich, tonnenschwere
storage system, das war was, das waren zeiten leute, sag ich euch 2007 2008, wenn tonnenschwere
storage systeme auf dem teppichboden im wohnzimmer stehen, voll bestückt, naja gut, naja gut,
so chat gibt es irgendwelche videos, aber wir wollten uns doch, moment, ihr habt doch
jetzt schon fünfmal gefragt, ob wir uns nicht dieses video angucken können, ja, alles ist
ein nft, ich bin zwar nicht so genau sicher was er uns sagen will, aber potentiell, so
wie es aktuell läuft mit nfts, kann alles potentiell als nft verkauft werden, weil du
verkaufst ja nicht das ding an sich, du verkaufst ja nur irgendwelche blockchain einträge,
die mit dem ding an sich überhaupt nichts zu tun haben, also insofern, ok gucken wir
uns das mal an, auf gehts, auf gehts, mal gucken wer diese zeitkapsel jemals finden
wird, das ist viel zu laut, ein kleptrap, wenn ich das schon sehe, das ist, auf twitter
die ganzen nft leute rennen mit so nem komischen affenavatar rum, ok die story kenn ich schon,
allerdings nicht von ihm, ja und eines tages ging ein besonderes teures ex, seltenes exemplar
nicht weg und daraufhin haben alle wie verrückt, wollten sie ihre tulpen loswerden und das
ist komplett gecrashed, stolz, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja soon
Dann kam das Internet und ein paar komische Zwischenschritte später entschloss sich 2008
mitten in der bislang größten Finanzkrise der Welt, einer bis heute immer noch unbekannten
Person namens Satoshi Nakamoto, das Gründungsdokument für eine Währung namens Bitcoin ins Internet
zu bringen.
Es weiß ja immer noch keiner mehr, dass es es gab ein paar Leute die behauptet haben
sie wären es, aber wahrscheinlich nur um daraus Kapital zu schlagen.
Eine Währung die unendliche finanzielle Sicherheit für die Menschheit bringen sollte, frei von
jeglicher staatlicher Kontrolle und jahrelang war die revolutionäre Währung namens Bitcoin
komplett wertlos.
Doch jeder hat den Satz mal gehört.
Hätte ich bloß damals Bitcoin gekauft.
Hallo, AnbickDSTB.
Ein Programmierer.
Und das geile ist der Typ der damals als einer der ersten, was damals bis durch die Presse
gegangen ist, da konnte sie irgendwie für acht Bitcoins oder so damals eine Pizza kaufen.
Der wird sich auch überlegt haben, so was heutiger sich ganz schön teure Pizza, aber
so kann man es ja nicht sehen.
Man muss ja sehen, was es zum damaligen Zeitpunkt wert war und dass es einem guter Tausch erschien
zur damaligen Zeit acht Bitcoins versus eine Pizza, weil es hätte genauso gut sein können,
dass er nie was dafür gekriegt hätte und das irgendwo in der Versenkung verschwunden
wäre.
Und da hat er jetzt eine Pizza gekriegt 2010 zehntausend Bitcoins gekauft und alle zehntausend
Bitcoins für eine Pizza ausgegeben.
Zehntausend war das sogar.
Spulen wir noch ein bisschen vor, langen wir in 2013.
Ein einziger Bitcoin ist jetzt tausend Dollar wert.
Der Typ hier hat zweihundert zwanzig Millionen Bitcoin auf seinem Music-B-Stick, aber sein
Passwort vergisst.
Er hat noch zwei Versuche es einzugeben.
Pech.
Jetzt wird sich alles auf dem Music-B-Stick automatisch löschen.
Der hier hatte auf seiner Festplatte 182 Millionen Euro in Bitcoin und hat die Festplatte damals
auf dieser Million.
Das kenn ich.
Das kenn ich noch.
Der ist dann von der Müllhalde wieder runterholen wollte.
Einfach weggeworfen.
Er sucht seit zehn Jahren die ganze Müllhalde ab.
Seit neuestem übrigens auch mit Roboterhunden.
Irgendwo habe ich den größten Schatz der Welt versteckt.
Und natürlich sind hier und da ein paar Menschen auch reich geworden mit Bitcoin.
Doch in einer ganz anderen Ecke vom Internet passieren währenddessen gar...
Was macht denn der Serious Max da in dem Bild?
... ganz andere Dinge.
Hier der Mensch spielt gerade Flappy Bird.
Twitch ist noch nicht voller Halbmarkter Frauen.
Harambe.
Eines der Memes war Pepe der Frosch.
Das Gesicht von Twitch und gleichzeitig auch das Lieblingsmeme und Maskottchen von Usern
auf 4chan.
Es war ein ganz normaler Tag auf dem Internetbord.
Doch plötzlich tweetete Katy Perry ein Pepe der Frosch-Meme, ein Dicht gefolgt von Nicki
Minaj.
Auch die Konkurrenzplattform Tumblr, mit der sich 4chan schon seit Jahren im Internetkrieg
befindet, erstellte plötzlich Seiten über Pepe...
Max, das war nix.
Man hat bloß den Avatar gesehen, den du im Discord hast.
Frosch.
4chan gefiel das gar nicht.
Und so kam einer auf die geniale Idee, sein Frosch-Bild zu signieren.
Und so wurde er geboren.
Pepe Nummer 1.
Spaghetti-Pepe.
Die anderen User waren empört und ziemlich schnell begann Diskussion über die bevorstehende
seltene Pepe-Bilder Economy.
Einer zeigt in einem Post plötzlich sein ganzes Pepe-Sortiment und plötzlich fing alle
anderen auch an seltene Pepe.
GARE PEPES, PLEASE DO NOT COPY PASTA.
Piss zusammen.
Ein paar Leute verschenkten welche umsonst.
Andere hingegen zeichneten selber welche, teilweise auch sehr verrückte Pepes.
Einfach um den Markt zu füllen.
Einer machte es sich zur Aufgabe von anderen Leuten die gesamten Pepes zu klauen.
Und nachdem schließlich Buzzfeed und andere YouTuber darüber berichteten, boten ein paar
User die seltensten Pepes, die noch kaum im Internet zu sehen waren, auf Ebay an.
Bienen-Pepe.
Pepe.
Seltene Pepe.
Bundle-Pack.
XXL-Pepe-Pack.
99-Gebot, 29-Gebot, 52-Gebot.
Gleichzeitig, irgendwo in Russland, arbeitete ein Dude namens Vitalik bereits an der nächsten
Kryptowährung.
Er spielte World of Warcraft leidenschaftlich.
Seit Jahren.
Seine Lieblingsklasse war Hexenmeister.
Mithilfe vom Lebenseinzug Zauber war er unglaublich stark.
Doch plötzlich ein Blizzard-Abbild.
Der Zauber wurde genervt.
Er weinte sich in den Schlaf mit der Erkenntnis, was für Gefahren ein zentrales, vereinbestimmendes
System mit sich bringen kann.
Erstmal ins Forum.
Erstmal ins Forum mit Blizzardflame.
Der zweite zweitgrößte Kryptowährung der Welt, Ethereum.
Und genau hier kommen auch die ersten Leute auf die Idee, Bitcoins zu minen.
Also ganz viele Computer in einem großen Wagenhaus aufstellen, die Bitcoins ersammeln
und gleichzeitig beten, dass das FBI oder irgendwelche Klimaleute nicht vor deiner Tür
stehen.
Da gibt's doch...
Da gab's doch erst letztens wieder was, also letztens vor so vornem Jahr oder so.
Da hat doch die Polizei, ich glaube das war in England, da hat die Polizei irgendein
Gebäude beobachtet und hat festgestellt, in diesem Gebäude herrscht eine sehr hohe Temperatur
im Vergleich zum umliegenden, zu den umliegenden Gebäuden.
Und dann ist die Polizei, da hat die Polizei das Gebäude gestürmt, weil sie gedacht haben,
da würde illegales Zeug angebaut.
Vape Nation Style.
Da hat irgendwie einer seine Plantage und was haben sie gefunden?
Eine Mining Farm.
Ja, da war nix, war noch nicht mal illegal, glaube ich mal zumindest.
Die crypto Währungen werden immer etablierter auf dem Markt und auch die Paypal Wirtschaft
wird davon betroffen.
Erst wurde die Seite Rare Paypal Wallet erstellt, ein großes Internetarchiv für alle mittlerweile
gefundenen Paypal Bilder.
Dort konnte man die JPEGs auch untereinander tauschen, erstmals für Bitcoin oder die neu
erschaffene Paypal Cash Währung.
Und weil 4Chen 4Chen ist, schaukelte sich das ganze hoch und dieser Paypal Homeup wurde
schließlich für 350.000 Paypal Cash digital verkauft und legte somit den Grundbaustein
für den Erwerb von digitalen Kunstwerken mit Hilfe von Kryptowährungen.
Und dann kam 2021.
Der Kryptomarkt ist gerade in der vollen Blüte.
Jeder kann Geld mit Kryptowährungen machen.
Hier hat ein Hamster, der durch Röhren läuft, ein ganzes Portfolio vervielfacht.
Das erinnert mich an den Typ, der seinen Fisch im Tank rumschwimmen hatte und dann irgendwie,
wenn der Fisch in der linken Hälfte des Aquariums war, Aktie A gekauft hat und wenn der Fisch
im rechten Hälfte des Aquariums war, Aktie B gekauft hat.
Und am Ende hat er Glück gehabt und die Fischaktien haben besser performt als die Wall Street
Empfehlungen.
Und dass das geht, sieht auch der Künstler Mike Winkleman aka, ich meine, es gibt sogar
Fisch-Plays-Pokemon, also nicht unterschätzen, was Fische so alles drauf haben.
Seit 13 Jahren täglich digitale Kunst ins Internet, angefangen mit ziemlich langweiliger
Kunst, entwickelten sich seine Artworks immer mehr.
Und dann kam er auf die Idee, die ersten 5.000 erstellten Bilder beim Auktionshaus Christie's
für ein bisschen Geld zu versteigern.
69 Millionen für ein NFT von seinem Bild.
Doch was ist überhaupt…
Aber Moment, Moment, man darf jetzt ja nicht vergessen, es ist jetzt ja nicht so als würde
das Bild jetzt diesem NFT-Besitzer gehören, also so nach dem Motto, der hat jetzt irgendwie
Vermarktungs- und sonst was-Rechte an diesem Bild, das hat er damit ja höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht erworben.
Nicht, dass man das irgendwie groß vermarkten könnte, vor allem für den krassen Preis.
Ein NFT.
Kunst in echt kann nachgemalt werden und egal wie gut man es macht, ist es niemals eine
exakte Kopie vom Gemälde.
Bei digitaler Kunst ist das anders.
Man könnte die Datei nehmen und hätte eine exakt gleiche Kopie.
Um genau dem vorzubeugen, wurden NFTs erfunden.
Jedes Bild wird mit einem Code ausgestattet.
Nur, dass du NFTs, die Bilder, weil sie nicht selbst in der Blockchain sind, auch einfach
noch kopieren kannst.
Und hast du den Code von diesem Gemälde, kannst du nachweisen, dass es tatsächlich
auch dir gehört.
Man kauft jedoch nicht das Bild an sich, sondern nur den Code, der zu dem Bild führt.
Man kauft auch nicht die Rechte an dem Bild, man kann das Bild also auch nicht vermarkten.
In 2021 wurde ein NFT von dem Buch Dune für 2,6 Millionen gekauft.
Der Käufer postete stolz, dass er aus Dune eine Serie machen will und die Netflix verkaufen
möchte.
Nur, dass vom Internet und sehr lustigen Schlagzeilen gesagt werden, dass das nicht gehen würde.
Wir haben die Auktion gewonnen, wir werden daraus eine Serie.
Ich habe die Auktion gewonnen, ich will daraus eine Serie machen, ich will daraus eine Serie
machen, ich will die Bibel 2 veröffentlichen.
Also, wozu...
Das Internet hat immer mal was auf Lager hier.
Bibel 2.0, Bibel NG, Bibelfork, das wär's aber.
...verkaufen können oder damit man digitale Eintrittstickets für zum Beispiel Konzerte
individualisieren kann oder nun ja, man macht das, was alle machen, NFTs kaufen und versuchen
sie für mehr Geld weiter zu verkaufen.
NFTs sind, als würde man in einem Laden Lebensmittel kaufen und nur mit dem Kassenzettel nach Hause
gehen.
Guck mal Leute, ich hab die Lebensmittel da drin gekauft.
Als andere Künstler sahen, dass Beeple's NFT für 69 Millionen verkauft wurde, fingen
auch diese an, ihre Werke ins Internet zu stellen.
Dann kam der Macher von Nyan Cat auf die Idee, seine animierte Katze als GIF im Internet zu
verkaufen.
Und kurz darauf fing alte Meme-Legenden an, sich oder ihre Werke im Internet als NFT zu
Erst war es Bad Luck Brian, dann die Keyboard-Katze und langsam aber sicher wuchs der NFT-Markt
immer...
Ich frag mich halt immer, was erwarten die Leute, die das kaufen und warum gibt's danach
nicht mehr enttäuschte Gesichter?
Die denken ja wahrscheinlich, sie haben jetzt wirklich die Rechte an diese Meme erworben
oder so.
Das ist nix.
Sie haben im Endeffekt einen Download-Link dazu.
Also, du kannst ja damit gar nichts machen.
Charlie Bit My Finger!
Die sind doch heute bestimmt auch schon 20, oder?
Na nee, nicht ganz.
15 oder so dürften doch auch schon mittlerweile sein.
Charlie Bit My Finger.
Charlie!
Es wurde übrigens in dem ganzen Video bisher noch nicht einmal gesagt, auf was NFT überhaupt
steht.
Gut, nicht dass es wirklich was bringen würde, weil die meisten wahrscheinlich eh nichts
mit anfangen können, aber... oder kam es am Anfang?
Wäre vielleicht am Anfang zumindest mal nicht schlecht?
NFT.
Unfassbar reich werden.
Kommt wahrscheinlich.
69 Millionen Dollar.
Oh mein Gott.
Erst wurden ziemlich viele zweitlassige Bilder gemalt.
Leute holten plötzlich ihre kreative Ader raus und versuchten andere davon zu überzeugen,
dass das hier Kunst sei.
No Fortnite Time.
Richtig chatten.
Wie wär's mit Screenshots aus Filmen und einfach mit ein bisschen Paint drüber malen?
Ja, das ist 35.000 Euro wert.
Berühmte Fotos nehmen, irgendwelche Filter drüber klatschen und größer wird meine Gemeldekollektion.
Steine in verschiedenen Farben für...
Die Leute, die das kaufen, die kaufen das doch nicht, weil sie sich denken, cool, ich
hab mir einen Stein-NFT gekauft, die spekulieren da doch, oder?
Die kaufen das und hoffen, dass es für 1500 weiterverkaufen können, oder?
Was anderes kann es doch nicht wirklich sein.
Das behält doch keiner und freut sich dann erst darauf, dass er einen Stein-NFT hat.
Der wohlgemerkt nicht mal der Stein selbst, sondern den Link, wahrscheinlich zu dem Steinbild.
Eine Million Euro.
Oh, die wurden tatsächlich auch gekauft.
Hier habt ihr noch mehr Steine.
Komm, wir klauen einfach Memes und oh warte, das machen ja andere schon.
Die Wiese da vorne könnte mindestens 20 Euro wert sein.
Der Himmel sieht heute wirklich schön aus.
Hey, guck mal, ein Straßenschiff.
80.000 Euro.
Ich nehme einfach meine Selfies und lade sie hoch.
Darauf kommt sicher kein anderer Internet.
Der Junge hier hat bereits mit seinen Selfies mehrere Millionen an Euro gemacht.
Okay, fuck.
Mein Fortnite Victory Royale.
NFT-Kollektion von Diktatoren.
Stock-Images aus dem Internet gezogen.
Andere NFTs runterladen, einen Strich drauf machen und selber verkaufen.
Bild kopieren, Strich drauf machen, nice, gutes Geschäftsmodell.
Von Ländern, Bilder von meiner Hand, einem Finger und mir das mit meinen Beinen für
50 Euro.
Leute, HowToBasic könnte ein NFT von seinem Fuß verkaufen, mit Ei drauf natürlich.
30.000 Euro.
Einfach eine einzige Farbe verkaufen.
Okay, jetzt bleibt mir keine Wahl mehr.
Ich ziehe mich nackt aus.
40.000 Euro.
Okay, warte, es gibt bereits eine ganze Seite, wo Leute ihre Nacktbilder als NFT verkaufen
können.
Okay, was zum Fick soll das hier sein?
Und jetzt denk zurück an die Tulpen.
Und das Einzige, was einen NFT-Preis bestimmt, ist die Nachfrage.
Also so viel, wie jemand anderes bereit ist.
Also so viel, wie jemand anderes bereit ist, für der Kunstwerk auszugeben.
Diese NFTs hier kosten 100 Milliarden.
Das ist mehr Geld, als es überhaupt auf der Welt gibt.
Der ganze Markt war schließlich voller NFTs, die eigentlich nur wertloser Müll waren.
Und plötzlich fingen die ersten Stars an, ihre eigenen NFTs zu verkaufen.
Jeder ist auf den Zug aufgesprungen.
Und dann kommt irgendwann noch demnächst Spielehersteller und sind da Meinung, ah, wir brauchen irgendwie
irgendwelche NFT-Geschichten übergreifend in unseren Games und das ist aber alles schon
ein bisschen, ein bisschen abgeflacht wieder.
Das war mal so ein ganz kleiner Hype und die Spielehersteller haben gemerkt, also irgendwie
will es keiner und so wirklich Sinn ergibt es auch nicht, also lassen wir es bleiben.
Aber das kommt bestimmt noch, das kommt in Zukunft, das kommt in Zukunft garantiert noch
mehr.
Das war jetzt so die erste Empörungswelle, das wird schon noch Einzug erhalten, gehe
ich mal stark von aus.
Mr.
Bean, Firmen wie Taco Bell oder Coca Cola machten mit und auch ein paar deutsche Promis
fingen an, NFTs anzubieten, das ganze Internet drehte sich nur noch um NFTs.
Ich habe übrigens jetzt nur mal auf eine Sache zu vergleichen, ich habe gesehen, dass
irgendwelche Fahrrad-Profis haben ihre Siege an Rennen als NFT verkauft, da fragt man sich
jetzt natürlich, wie soll das gehen, das Rennen war ja schon, er hat gewonnen, wie kannst
du einen Sieg an einem Rennen verkaufen, ergibt ja eigentlich keinen Sinn.
So und was war es im Endeffekt?
Es war das Siegerfoto, aber es war nicht mal das Siegerfoto, weil an dem Siegerfoto hatte
der Fotograf mit Rechte, es war quasi eine billig nachgemachte Version des Siegerfotos
und das haben Leute dann wirklich gekauft, da fragt man, was ist mit euch los, Kratz-FPS-NFT,
auf geht's, ja.
Stopp, denkst du es ist witzig, meine NFTs zu klauen, lösch den Screenshot, hör auf
den Besitz von anderen Leuten zu klauen, das ist deine letzte Wahl.
Moment mal, den gibt es gehört denen ja überhaupt nicht, ich glaube die haben das alle nicht
so ganz verstanden.
Guck mal, ich habe ein NFT gekostet, oder meinst du unseren NFT?
Der NFT hier ist wirklich krass, ich habe den gleichen NFT.
Und so brach ein ganzer Krieg zwischen NFT-Hardlinern und Trollen im Internet aus.
Erst hat es mit ein paar Leuten angefangen, dann machten ganze Firmen bei der mittlerweile
Sport mit NFT-Leute zu bissen, der hier hatte ganz andere Dinge mit dem NFT von jemanden.
Hier hat jemand 100 NFTs von Furries zu einem zusammengefügt und es für 100.000 Dollar
verkauft, einer hat 10.000 von den hässlichen Löwen-NFTs hier zu einem großen Mosaik zusammengefügt,
in dem eine Person rechtsklickt, ein ganzer Doom-Mod, bei dem man üben kann hässliche
Affen-NFTs zu Screenshotten, eine ganze Seite, mit der man mit einem Klick alle NFTs auf
der Blockchain runterladen kann.
Der NFT hier ist so hässlich, dass man ihn nicht mal Screenshotten wollte.
NFT-Leute haben dann versucht, dem entgehen zu sorgen, indem sie den Begriff Rechtsklicker-Mentalität
einführten, um andere zu regadieren, nur um dann noch mehr verarscht zu werden.
Twitter führte dann ein Hexagon-Profilbild ein, mit dem man sein NFT mit den Handelsplattformen
verlinken konnte.
Das kam nicht sehr gut an und hat die Sache eigentlich nur noch schlimmer gemacht.
Das ist aber eines der Sachen, wo man eine halbwegs sinnvolle Anwendung sieht von sowas,
weil da kann es dann nicht, also wenn die jeweilige Plattform das supportet, in der
jeweiligen Blockchain, wo das dann auch drüber getradet wurde, also wahrscheinlich werden
die Plattformen in Zukunft lieber was eigenes machen, dass es dann irgendwie was sinnvolles
ist, weil das kannst du dann auch nicht mehr faken in dem Sinn, weil Twitter kann machen,
was sie wollen im Endeffekt dann mit ihrer Implementierung, aber das kannst du dann nicht
mehr faken, also sprich, wenn du Plattformen hast, wo das integriert ist und die das dann
nachgucken, dass du dann auch wirklich nur als derjenige, der dann die richtigen Bites
besitzt, das verlinken kannst, das ist dann wieder was anderes.
Du kannst natürlich keinen von abhalten, den gleichen NFT als Avatar rein zu machen,
aber es ist dann halt nicht so ein Ding drum.
Und hier fingen auch die restlichen Promis an, NFTs anzubieten.
Erst nahm man uns auf diese Weise Johnny Sins, dann Eminem, der sogar ein ganzes Musikvideo
zu den Affen-NFTs released, dann Haspula, KSI, ein deutscher YouTuber verkaufte sogar
sein Lamborghini für ein NFT, und der hier hat gleich seine ganze Niere verkauft.
Hier fing man dann noch an, alte Legenden wie Bob Ross oder Stan Lee, also Leute, die
schon lange tot sind, auszugraben, um NFTs unter ihrem Namen zu verkaufen.
NFTs sind unter anderem so hässlich, weil sie mithilfe von Programmen die verschiedenen
Körperteile aneinander rein erstellt werden und deshalb rein...
Das ist ja auch total easy.
Das ist überhaupt gar kein Sinn ergeben.
Also so Dinge zu...
Das ist wirklich easy as fuck.
Da beauftragst du für 5,50 Euro jemanden bei Fiverr und erstellst 10 verschiedene Base-Sachen,
die du dann kombinierst und machst hunderte NFTs.
Und dann auch unterschiedliche Farben dabei und du machst tausende NFTs.
Und eines dieser Bilder hat eine längere Geschichte.
Irgendwo im tiefen Schnee von Russland...
GigaChat, oder was kommt jetzt?
Christa Sudmales an Bilder von Männern als Kunstprojekt.
Doch, doch GigaChat!
Eines Tages fand ein Fortune-User, wer sonst, ein von diesen Männern.
Ein perfektes Kind, pure Männlichkeit, pures Testosteron.
Bin nicht schwul, aber ich würde sein Cockloot.
Wie will ich damit mithalten?
Ich werde als Jungfrau sterben.
Daraufhin machte man sich jahrelang auf die Suche nach der Identität des Mannes, der
an diesem Tag der GigaChat getauft wurde.
Vier Jahre später erfuhr man schließlich, dass er von den Memes gehört hat, aber jegliche
Art von Businessanfragen und Interviews ablehnen wird, weil er mit keinem kooperieren möchte
und nicht wüsste, dass ein Podcast sei.
Der Mann namens Ernest Kalimov wurde schließlich zur Legende und prägt eine...
Der sieht ja...
Der sieht ja wirklich exakt GigaChat-mäßig aus.
Ach...
Ich hätte jetzt eher gedacht, dass das Foto jetzt halt unter sehr günstigen Bedingungen
aufgenommen wird.
Aber das sieht...
Bis heute sah man sich noch zahlreiche Anhänger und...
Der sieht ja wirklich exakt GigaChat-mäßig aus.
Und disleggen fleißig alle anderen ohne ein GigaChat-Profilbild runter.
Bis man schließlich erfuhr, dass es diesen Mann nicht gibt.
Ach.
Die Künstlerin Photoshoppte die verschiedenen Models von ihrem Projekt jeweils zum perfekten
Bild von einem giga chat zurecht alter der Typ erzählt mir doch nicht dass es
Fake war
und interviews ablehnen wird weil er mit keinem kooperieren möchte und nicht
wüsste dass ein podcast sei der mann namens alter der Typ sieht auch wirklich
so aus also hätte er zu mir gesagt er ist giga chat dann das er ist oder ist
das oder ist das bild auch fake oder ist das auch fake wurde schließt sich zur
legende und bringt eine ganz bis heute sammeln sich noch zahlreiche anhänger
unter dem kommentarbereich von und deswegen fleißig alle anderen ohne ein
giga chat profil bild rundherum bis man schließt sich erfuhr dass es diesen mann
nicht gibt die künstlerin photoshopte die verschiedenen models von ihrem
projekt jeweils zum perfekten bild von einem giga chat zurecht als tribut
achso der bereits seit jahren verstorben mal ist es ihr freund mal ist es ein
anderes model tut mir leid euch das sagen zu müssen aber den giga chat gibt
es ein menschlicher form nicht jetzt bin ich aber schwer enttäuscht das wusste
ich gar nicht dass der fake ist der giga chat
jetzt bin ich jetzt bin ich schon etwas mitgenommen
ist nicht realer giga chat denn er lebt bereits in uns allen es ist nur unsere
aufgabe zu erwecken auch der giga wird heute als nft verkauft der nft markt
erreichte schließlich den höchsten und damit die preise nicht noch weiter
sanken kam die nft community schließt sich auf ein paar geniale wege um ihre
kunstwerke zu bewerben und wertvoll aussehen zu lassen diese künstlerin
verkaufte 14 gläser und sofern du einen exklusiven ist ja noch schlimmer als
game of gold badewasser fahrt ja nft dazukaufs eine ganze tv show mit mila
kunis und eschen kutscher die nur gucken kannst du einen teil von der nft
kondition gekauft hast der ganze time square voller nft werbung leute trugen
ihre nft seit kette wer braucht eine rolex wenn man das hier haben kann sogar
die leinwand von r slash plays wurde beschmutzt mit werbung für scam projekte
gottseidank als streamer dann relativ schnell vernichtet
fuck nft ziemlich kontroverse nft cosplays nft serien die umsonst zu schauen sind und
dann komplett gedislike werden und of what non fungible token non fuckable
duken all you need to know kutterspaces wohl leute ihre nfts
ropeln und was glaubt ihr passiert das bin ich sehnt der 11,7 million dollar
wert ist und 200 kilogramm wiegt einfach so mitten in new york aufstellt nun das
internet macht das was es am besten kann mein kraft mein kraft keine sorge ich
habe schon immer dafür trainiert fortnight fort ok boys wie können wir
diesen gold block der von vielen securities bewacht wird am besten
stehlen helikopter mit einem magneten dran sollte mehr als genug sein
scheiße oder vielleicht doch fortgeschritten nach der technologie ok
what the fuck oder ein foto machen als nft verkaufen
ich verkaufe ja genau das dachte ich mir von game of thrones der den gold block
einfach wegträgt ein enterhaken zu kompliziert eine käsefirma stellte
plötzlich daneben eine riesige käse packung auf nun auch der gold block war
ein nft stand der ziemlich in die hose ging ich meine stellt euch vor ihr seid
obdachlos und plötzlich ist ein fucking gold block vor euch und man sagt euch
das ist werbung für einen non fungible token drop bro der würfel wurde nach einem
tag wieder weggefahren und jetzt wieder zu den anderen werbemethoden eine dating
app ausschließlich für leute mit einem affen nft die scheiterte daran dass sich
zu 98 prozent männer anmelden wer hätte es gedacht eine ganze da hätte man ja
nicht mit rechnen können also im prinzip so wie jede andere dating app auch
krypto land
sofern du einen nft besitzt also krypto land kann ja mal gar nicht gegen also
gar nicht gegen mit connect anstehen anstehen carlos matos vom new york city
darfst du auf dieser insel leben und mit anderen nft krypto kumpeln coole sachen
unter die stress rule a pool full of coins
wo an das break schließlich scheiterte was wird es das einwilligungsalter in
krypto land sein mental erwachsen sollte mehr als genug sein
tötet sie alle und schließlich der board ja die größte nft community die man
überall im internet für sehr hohe preise zu sehen bekommt eminem post malo
justin bieber wirklich jeder redete über die größte nft kondition von allen
moment paris hilton gibt es noch ja gut wie man die weiß nicht so alt warum
soll es sie nicht mehr geben aber es gibt leute die hatten wir schon wieder
komplett verdrängt als clubmember bekam man verschiedene vorteile und konnte
diesmal tatsächlich sein affen nft vermarkten ein ganzes festival wurde
exklusiv nur für leute mit diesem nft veranstaltet der vip bereich ließ zur
wünschen übrig aber die partys und veranstaltungen um diesen club waren
ziemlich riesig leute tätowierten sich das logo trugen hoodies verkauften
merch ganze restaurants wurden gegründet cover auf dem rolling stones
magasin überall war das board jachtclub logo zu sehen und kommt es euch bekannt
vor denn das hier ist das logo der nationalsozialistischen waffen ss
schutzstaffel auf
exakt 18 zähne gleiche anreihung gleiche schrift gleich positioniert nun es kann
sein dass die vier gründer vom board ab jachtclub fortune user waren und es
witzig fanden subtile rechtsradikale botschaften in den nft zu verstecken in
jedem der vier namen der founder sind versteckte anspielungen zur ns im
board ab jachtclub video spiel kamen auch ganz zufällig mit einer sehr
verdächtigen form schießt und eventuell wurden auch viele geheime zahlen und
calls in nfts versteckt um sich über die ns zeit lustig zu machen wer will kann
sich dazu dass ein stunden die du hier angucken die verfahren dazu sind immer
noch am laufen doch scams existieren schon immer in der
kunstgeschichte vor ein paar jahren hat jemand mal eine unsichtbare skulptur für
18.000 dollar verkauft und ist meant to activate the viewers imagination
oh mein gott endlich
wo wir wieder beim thema sind leute es ist ja nicht verboten scheiße zu
verkaufen das alles verkaufen und das die leute bloß also wo es dann kriminell
wird ist wenn du den leuten erzählst es ist nicht scheiße das ist irgendwas ganz
tolles und das doch scheiße du kannst auch luft verkaufen ist überhaupt kein
ding solange die leute wissen was sie kriegen und der sache zustimmen ist das
alles in ordnung und du kannst du kannst auch durch geschickte umschreibungen
vielleicht die leute was anderes vermuten lassen ja das ist ja das was
seit jahren jeder laden mehr oder weniger macht und das ist jetzt also die
spitze das ganzen wieder
aber es nicht verboten scheiße zu verkaufen leute wusstet ihr dass man
vlc kaufen kann auf einer cd
oder auf usb kann so voll z bestellen ganz voll z kaufen macht keinen sinn für
sich voll z zu kaufen kann sie voll z sogar im mediamarkt oder und die beim
saturn oder so war beim saturn genau beim saturn kann sie voll z kaufen
es ist nicht verboten scheiße zu verkaufen wichtig ist halt vorher dass
sie also wichtig ist dass die leute nicht anlügst kann sich sagen ich verkaufe
dir voll z oder kann ich kann sich sagen ich verkaufe dir irgendwie denn 256 g usb
nicht so eingeht drauf das geht halt nicht dann hast du danach probleme aber ansonsten
ist das erlaubt künstler hinter der unsichtbaren skulptur wird beklagt von
einem anderen unsichtbar künstler diese banane an einer wand festgeklebt ist
120.000 euro wert und dann wurde die banane gegessen doch mit der digitalen
welt voller influencer und der voll z-player der weltberühmte
unter irgendeine kryptowährung erstellt sehr viel geld rein investieren diese
dankbar macht eigentlich dort gekäuft oder frauen auf feiber aktuell die
währung auf den körper malen alle anderen investieren jetzt auch in die
revolutionäre neue kriptowährung und der chart sollte jetzt ungefähr so so oder
so aussehen nimm mal dein geld mach profil lösche alle profil und versteck
dich irgendwo auf einer insel 2.168 trillion dollars trillion was war das
2.1 trillion na gut die ami billion sind ja auch keine billionen 6 8 trillion
dollars meine 2,8 millionen dollar sind jetzt 1000 dollar wert mann verliert
geld für die hochzeit wegen kripto scam versucht ein laden aus zu rauben um
geld wieder zu bekommen landet zwei jahre im knast behörden fahnden weltweit
nach one coin erfinderin die ist jetzt übrigens die siebte meistgesuchte
person der welt kriptowährung start-up verschwindet mit benis nachricht und im
mal 2022 kam dann schließlich der krypto crash und zeitgleich sagt auch immer
mehr das interesse für nfts es ging schon lange nicht mehr um kunst und
immer mehr betrugsvorfälle und scams machten schlagzeit was die öffentliche
begeisterung der leute für kriptowährungen und wer hätte das
gedacht dass es im kripto umfeld scams gibt das ist ja nicht auszudenken es
gab noch nie scams im kripto umfeld also das ist also wer so ernsthaft wie
kommt man darauf dass im kripto umfeld irgendjemand scammed alles kann ich
sein es gibt tatsächlich auch heute noch ein paar sind die geisters krank oder
irgendwie sind die sind irgendwie komplett verrückt es gibt tatsächlich
auch heute noch ein paar aber bei den meisten wenn sie gefühlt keine leute
die meisten menschen auf dem nft markt machen heute geld damit in dem sie ihre
kunstwerke untereinander verkauft zusammengefasst nft projekte von
firmen und entwicklern wurden gekennts und nft stück für stück gemeinsam aus
dem internet gemobbt damit die welt wieder zu ihrer vollen reinheit
zurückkehren konnte ich glaube aber habe ich vorhin schon gesagt dass gerade
spielehersteller also das gab ja ein riesen bei ganz vielen versuche eine
riesen shitstorm und die haben das auch zum größten teil alles wieder
eingestellt man hat nie wieder was von gehört aber ich glaube dass das den
spielherstellern beziehungsweise eher den größeren publishers schon ideen für
die zukunft gegeben hat wir werden das in so oder so ähnlicher form in zukunft
auch in games sehen allerdings dann hat jeder hersteller natürlich in der
eigene trading plattform und geschützt drumherum und wo sie an jeder
transaktions beteiligt sind für 2,9 millionen dollar gekauft wurde ist heute
270 dollar werden logan pauls nft für 620.000 dollar ist heute 10 dollar für
eine million dollar wurde für 1 cent verkauft justin bieber ist nft für 2,9
millionen 69
das internet so ist es halt
also aber gerade im krypto umfeld leute ohne miss da wundert mich echt nichts
mehr also wer da noch davon ausgeht
nicht gescannt zu werden muss ja fast schon sagen
dem ist nicht mehr zu helfen
ja die stories gibt es immer wieder
gibt auch die leute die sagen hey ich habe bitcoin kram gemacht hat mir jetzt
zwei häuser gekauft ehemals ja kollege bei mir auf der
arbeit er war auch vor jahren total interessiert an krypto zeug hat
ergeblich auch mehrere bitcoins gehabt und hat sie nicht mehr also insofern
so hat du wirst bei sowas immer auch gewinner haben aber es darf man aber
nicht vergessen dass es vielleicht ein paar gewinner gibt klar aber es gibt zum
größten teil mehr also es gibt deutlich mehr verliere als gewinner
twitch prime massive scam ja das ist quasi direkt bezahs überweisen wenn
ich es nicht einsetzt wohlgemerkt ist quasi ein reverse scam also wenn man es
nicht einsetzt ist problematisch
also lasst euren primes ab nicht verfallen
weißt du nicht wie das prinzip in den bitcoin eigentlich funktioniert nur sehr
der nur so grob sehr grob sehr grob das hängt irgendwie davon ab wie viele
leute am meinen sind also es ist ja es ist ja so dass jede transaktion quasi
designiert werden muss jede bitcoin transaktion und dafür brauchst du
rechenpower
und
du wirst dann quasi mit dem meinen dass du diese rechenpower zur verfügung
stellst ist irgendwie unter anderem dafür belohnt dass du transaktionen
signierst und es hängt auch irgendwie davon ab wie viele leute gerade am meinen
sind also richtig also tiefen durchblick habe ich da nicht von nur so ganz ganz
grob
also es kann ich dir nicht genau erklären
ja im endeffekt schon nicht gleich und gleich und wenn er nicht gelöst
da wird wahrscheinlich viel trial error gemacht und irgendwann kommt dann was
passendes raus ich habe keine ahnung wie es genau funktioniert ja genau so dass
das verstehe ich auch soweit aber wozu man das genau benutzt und wie das
aufgebaut ist keine ahnung
da muss sie also wenn du es genau wissen willst musst du mir in erklär video
angucken das kann also ich weiß es nicht dementsprechend kann ich dir auch nicht
erklären
du hast mit deinem ethereum gewinnt ein gamer pc finanziert
oder stellt euch mal vor ich habe mir den gamer pc finanziert ohne krypto
könnt ihr euch das vorstellen ganz ohne krypto gewinne habe ich mein
gaming pc finanziert unglaublich aber war
war ja switch von hinders to mac os ja kann man ja nachvollziehen
wenn aus geht er mir auch auf den sack aber der grund warum ich windows verwende
der ist dann mit mac os nicht gelöst deswegen verwende ich weiter windows und
für alles andere linux
pippo fed time chat chat blick durch
soll ich euch darauf mal die antwort geben was schneller ist rast oder c plus
plus ohne dass wir das video geguckt haben die antwort ist es hängt vom skill
level und ahnung des programmierers ab in der jeweiligen sprache dass es die
realistisch der antwort ich darauf geben kann und so wird es am ende auch sein
es hängt davon ab wie gut die leute in der jeweiligen sprache sich auskennt du
kannst sicherlich super crazy optimisation zu machen in c plus plus und
auch ganz abgedrehten shit in rust wahrscheinlich wenn du richtig plan
hast am ende gibt es für die jeweilige für das jeweilige problem also ein mehr
oder weniger optimalen ablauf und du musst halt gucken dass du möglichst nah
mit der sprache drankommst also ab optimal ablauf meine ich das was deine
cpu ausführt es gibt einen theoretisch optimalen weg wie das ganze machen
kannst und du musst halt dass in deiner sprache so implementieren dass du
möglichst nah an diesem optimalen weg bist und dazu musst du sicherlich auch
ganz viele abgedrehten low level hacks beherrschen in beiden sprachen und dann
hast du sicherlich ein paar sachen die von der jeweiligen implementierung abhängen
wenn du halt nicht super krasse low level optimierung machst oder in line
assembler bei c plus plus solche geschichten dann hängt es wahrscheinlich
auch ein bisschen vom problem ab je nachdem wie was implementiert ist in der
jeweiligen standard library oder in der jeweiligen sprache oder bei den
jeweiligen eingesetzt compiler ist rast eigentlich objekt orientiert kann man
das so pauschal nicht sagen doch kann man sagen man kann sagen dass rast er
nicht objekt orientiert ist rast ist er so in dem in die funktionale richtung es
gibt beispielsweise auch keine klassen in rast es gibt es gibt objekte in dem
sinn es gibt es gibt zwar objekte wobei das keine weiß weil ich glaube die
heißen das heißt den rast auch nicht mal
objekte ja ist das in rast überhaupt types
einfach nur types glaube ich gelten rast nennt glaube ich einfach nur types
es ist ein bisschen wie in go
du kannst wenn du willst ein bisschen op machen ganz verschiedene ganz quasi
struts anlegen mit hohen für struts sowas das funktioniert schon aber es ist
nicht vom designer so gedacht
ich glaube man kann es ganz gut mit mit go vergleichen nur dass rast die
deutlich abgedrehtere syntax hat für viele dinger also rast kannst du ohne
probleme fast eine komplette zeile mit sonderzeichen füllen also krass ist es
nicht aber also rast ist nicht unbedingt die lesbarste sprache
jetzt können wir uns noch angucken jetzt halbe stunde zeit habe ich noch ein
remote tag als software entwickler ok wir haben uns das letzte mal glaube ich
von ihm schon den einen tag als software entwickler angeguckt da können wir uns
einen remote tag als software entwickler noch angucken und das letzte video habe
ich auch schon gesagt fand ich nicht schlecht glaube zumindest dass das das
video von ihm gewesen ist wo ich gesagt habe das fand ich nicht schlecht weil es
eben nicht darum ging hallo wir spielen den ganzen tag tisch kicker oder sitzen
mit unserem laptop in der kantine und und super fun funny in sitzkissen und so
was sondern da wurde wirklich was geschafft von 9 bis abends
zwar nicht jede minute es geht auch nicht kann es ja nicht jede minute darf
voll konzentrieren und kreative arbeit machen
das kommt man zwar was mani remotes episode 1 ist das sogar naja episode 1
es geht dann quasi von morgens bis 10 uhr willkommen zurück heute zeige ich
euch ein bisschen von meinem remote setup aus spanien von wo aus ich den
nächsten was habe ich jetzt gedrückt ich zeige euch aus spanien wollte gerade
sagen warum sieht es da so karg aus drum herum hier alles auch am tisch aus
spanien das natürlich nice wie mein setter wo man schon mal wieder sieht
homeoffice einfach beste so was wäre früher nicht möglich gewesen und er
macht immer noch wichtige sachen für das unternehmen bin ich mir sicher ist
egal ob er in spanien sitzt oder bei sich daheim
so aussieht was ich so mitgenommen habe an welchen aufgaben ich gerade arbeite
und am ende des videos gibt es noch eine ziemlich coole überraschung für euch
meine liebe community also dran bleiben lohnt ein nft ich viel spaß
voll übertrieben aber so laut wir haben uns vor ein paar tagen auf die reise
gemacht von münchen nach banos dem olgas das ist wirklich so ein absolutes
kleines kaffee sieht man sieht es ist bestimmt sehr ruhig und angenehm
draußen schönes wetter man kann da schön durch grüne laufen so ein bisschen
über die felder bestimmt nice in der pampa in spanien aber super süß
richtig ja das doch ist halt einfach super remote also hier ist wirklich gar
nichts hier gibt es nur alte leute natur und wahnsinnig viel ruhe
die opas sagen da kommt man da ist der komische der verrückte deutsche wieder
der ganzen tag im zimmer sitzt an seinem laptop
franz franz ist ein sehr best name für den hund findet ihr nicht auch
offensichtlich konnte ich meine riesen setup aus münchen nicht mitnehmen
deshalb musste ich mich wirklich auf die sachen beschränken die ich wirklich
brauche zum einen ist das natürlich mein mc book denn ohne mein mc kann ich
halt einfach nicht arbeiten dazu habe ich noch ein paar geräte von der
arbeit mitgenommen wie zum beispiel dieses ipad wie geht er denn wie geht
dann da ins internet wahrscheinlich per per lte oder oder per 5g oder diesen
google chrome carsten den brauche ich für das feature an dem ich oder haben
die dann schnell internetanschluss im hotel wobei das ja kein hotel ist in der
ferienwohnung oder gerade arbeite ja dann habe ich noch diese laptop
erhöhung mitgenommen ganz einfach damit ich nicht immer nur nach unten schaue
meine maus und noch meine tastatur ich dachte wirklich dass ich an alles
gedacht habe und als ich dann auf dem weg zum flughafen war hat mich meine
frau gefragt hast du auch wirklich alles für die arbeit mitgenommen
ja natürlich habe ich mein netzteil vergessen natürlich dass es hier im
dorf kein elektrofachmarkt gibt deswegen bin ich am münchner flughafen einfach
noch in einen von diesen elektro läden gerannt hat mir für 70 euro dieses viel
zu teurer hat verwandtschaft hat er das gesagt dann habe ich nicht gehört
gekauft aber was soll ich machen ohne strom kann ich ja nicht arbeiten für
internet benutze ich diesen kleinen mobilen hotspot dort steckt eine sim
karte mit unlimitierten datenvolumen ok es funktioniert super und wir haben gar
keine probleme internet ist wirklich schnell genug so und jetzt wo mein
setup komplett aufgebaut ist würde ich sagen schneller als hier in ländlichen
gebieten in deutschland teilweise arbeit loslegen
aktuell arbeite ich an einer relativ großen aufgabe und zwar ist das ein
komplettes redesign unseres casting features casting bedeutet eigentlich
nur dass ich von meinem iphone oder ipad aus irgendwie einen film oder eine
serie oder ein fernseher schauen kann und dann wenn ich einen chromecast zu
hause an meinem fernseher stecken habe dann kann ich das bild direkt an meinen
chromecast pushen deshalb habe ich auch diesen chromecast aus münchen mitgenommen
im ersten schritt habe ich diese übersichtsliste neu programmiert wo
alle verfügbaren chromecasts aufgelistet werden die sich in meinem
netzwerk befinden das funktioniert schon ganz gut dafür habe ich natürlich wie
immer eine design vorlage bekommen und mein kollege schaut sich gerade die
codeänderungen an sobald man sich dann mit einem chromecast verbunden hat
funktioniert das iphone oder ipad praktisch als fernbedienung ich kann
also den video stream der jetzt auf meinem chromecast an meinem fernseher
ähm was arbeitet der noch mal weipu ne weifu tv läuft von meinem
smartphone aus steuern also ich kann die lautstärke verändern spulen pausieren
und so weiter und natürlich auch umschalten das aktuelle design ist so ein
bisschen angestaubt weshalb wir uns dazu entschlossen haben ein komplettes
redesign zu machen und ich finde natürlich auch dass es viel besser
aussieht das design habe ich mir natürlich nicht selbst ausgedacht
sondern wir haben dafür ein professionelles team und unsere
designerin hat dann diese vorlage in zeppelin hochgeladen und ich versuche
dir jetzt was ist denn zeppelin ist das sowas wie so ein mock-up tool oder was
was was ist zeppelin
wie ist wie ist dieses andere designer tool was die letzten jahre über so
angesagt war fick mal ja fick fick mal was war die letzten jahre über so
angesagt genau
im code eins zu eins so nach zu programmieren ich habe jetzt hier auch
kein fernseher rumstehen weshalb ich so ein hdmi grabber benutze damit das
chromecast signal praktisch als webcam in meinen mac rein läuft so kann ich dann
sehen ob alles funktioniert
aber die musik
der text gleich gleich
kommt im hintergrund einer reingestürmt oder so
norders
der sonnenstand verändert sich aber jetzt auch nicht wirklich im
hintergrund
also man könnte fast vermuten das wurde für das video noch mal extra
aufgenommen
ich könnte damit wahrscheinlich auch nicht den ganzen tag arbeiten mit einem
laptop bildschirm ich bräuchte auch ich bräuchte schon den ordentlichen
bildschirm aber ich glaube es ist gewöhnungssache
ich glaube es ist einfach gewöhnungssache wenn du gewöhnt bist tagsüber
also tag ein tag aus nur mit einem notebook bildschirm klarzukommen da
kommst du damit irgendwie klar aber ich persönlich würde es auch nicht so nicht
so mögen
mal feierabend machen
franz geht spazieren
ich finde franz ist ein geiler name für den dackel
franz finde es da bestimmt toll mein schwager hat so eine dji mavic drohne und
ich darf die mir mal ein bisschen ausleihen und habe einfach mal bock
hier in der gegend ein bisschen rum zu fliegen
mein zu 2k ist mindestens pflicht ich habe auch 1080p noch weil ich halt max
fps bin und mindestens 240 herz plus bildschirm haben will aber mein nächster
bildschirm wird entweder wenn es gescheite gibt ein gescheites 120 herz
oled also nicht der den es jetzt aktuell gibt und
probleme hat mit schrift rendering
und so lange behalte stehen der nächste wird an 1044 p 120 herz
oled wenn es da mal was gescheites gibt oder vielleicht auch vielleicht auch
nicht in 50 zoll lg den kleineren lg den den 27 zoll ist das glaube ich
oder oder ich kaufe mir 1440 p bildschirm allerdings wie gesagt 240 herz
plus muss sein 360 muss nicht wirklich sein aber 240
sollte sollte sollte schon sein
rüdiger rüdiger keine kapriolen
war das kapriolen überhaupt rüdiger
sollen jetzt zum abschluss noch zu meiner überraschung für euch und zwar
habe ich neulich meine website auf ein neues design umgezogen und da habe ich
mir gedacht dass es doch eigentlich ganz cool wäre wenn ich meine eigenen
wallpaper hätte gesagt getan ich muss ehrlich sagen ich mag das
webseiten design ist hier warum weil es nicht so übertrieben designed ist es
könnte fast eine webseite von 1995 sein klar das font rendering ist besser und
es sieht alles ein bisschen runder und moderner aus aber es ist im prinzip ein
weißer hintergrund mit schwarzem text also das könnte mehr oder weniger
webseite von 1995 sein paper hätte gesagt getan ich habe drei
wunderschöne wallpaper für euch entwickelt hier jetzt auf meiner
webseite kostenlos runterladen könnt mein allererstes wallpaper pack habe ich
dem namen flow gegeben denn für jede coding zeit wollte ich ein passendes
wallpaper haben angefangen mit dem roten hotlines of code wallpaper für den
coolen abend gibt es das wallpaper cool ich muss mal meinen designer fragen was
die pepo die die pepo wallpaper machen
zum blau und ein absoluter favorit die night session alle wallpaper gibt es den
knackscharfer 6k auf lösung 4k ist ja auch für kaknup so muss schon mindestens
6k sein würde natürlich auch interessieren erst mal ei abscale auf 120
k wie das wallpaper bei euch so aussieht also können wir wenn ich nicht eine
eigene ssd für das wallpaper brauche ist es nicht scharf genug ja gerne ein
foto eure setups auf instagram in eine story packen oder vielleicht auch auf
twitter und mich am besten direkt markieren ich werde hier aus meiner zeit
in spanien sicher den ein oder anderen lock raushauen
falls ihr euch gefallen dann auf jeden fall ein abo dalassen falls ihr das
video sonst gefallen hat würde ich mich also ich ich mag ja hunde
normalerweise nicht also
wo war franz aber franz finde ich cool falls ihr euch gefahren franz ist nice
meine ich würde würde kein hund haben wollen ja ich bin mit meiner katz zu
vergehen aber franz franz dann auf jeden fall abo dalassen falls ihr das video
sonst gefallen hat würde ich mich wie immer bei den daumen nach oben freuen
wie gesagt abonnieren nicht vergessen um keine weiteren videos zu verpassen ich
hoffe wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal da
was haben wir ein bisschen spanien gesehen heute
die besten raspberry pi alternativen lasst mich raten es gibt auch nicht ziti
abling ist dieser dieser dieses diskussions ding das gucken uns jetzt nicht
an es gibt keine alternativen für den
raspberry pi es gibt zwar hardware alternativen aber es gibt keine
alternativen für raspberry pi wenn es um verfügbare tutorials software support
extra hardware hätte dafür gibt ordentliches betrieb sind verbreitetes
betriebssystem mit allem was man braucht gibt einfach ist das tatsächlich
ziemlich konkurrenzlos der raspberry pi ja es gibt verschiedene hardware die
ähnlich ist oder wenn ich sogar besser ist als der raspberry pi und billiger
aber das ganze ökosystem drumherum hat nur der raspberry pi
ado ino kommt am nächsten ado ino haben raspberry pi man gar nichts zu tun
ado ino ist microcontroller raspberry pi ist ein vollständiger mini pc wo
linux drauf läuft ein vollständiger mini computer wo linux drauf läuft
es macht eigentlich die legalisierung für dass die leute hier offiziell
nation machen können haben sie noch groß angekündigt gut ich
meine wir haben auch vor ein paar jahren abgestimmt über das abschaffen der
sommer winterzeit also von der zeitumstellung hat ja auch keinen
wirklich interessiert sind wir noch am start ist jetzt auch bald übrigens
wieder heute kam ein sink center an ist aber kein ersatz von raspberry pi wir
schließen zum beispiel an ein sink center irgendwelche gpio header von
raspberry pi an gar nicht sage ich halt das ganze ökosystem drumherum ist halt
bei allen anderen platformen nicht so ausgeprägt wie beim raspberry pi du
findest sicherlich für einen speziellen anwendungszweck alternativen zum
raspberry pi wenn du glück hast aber das gesamtpaketen das ökosystem drumherum
ist immer noch einzigartig beim raspberry pi und das wird sich auch so
schnell nicht ändern
da ist das wiederum kein problem da bist du wahrscheinlich sogar mit einem
sin klein und x86 kiste und am strich besser bedient als mit dem raspberry pi
alles in frage das was man was man machen will
die normas ist ein bisschen machst du da bestimmt nichts verkehrt
hauptsache du hast ein paar usb anschlüsse noch an dem sin klein für
irgendwelche sticks seawave sick be matter die thread ist es ja eigentlich
weil weil matter ist ja nur das logische um drüber oder irgendwelche anderen
funktdinger also bei heim automatisierungskiste
brauchst immer ein paar usb anschlüsse ohne wir das nix
ich würde hauptsache nicht im container laufen lassen ich würde
tatsächlich hauptsache in a vm oder
bear metal laufen lassen ja vor allem ist ok das dumme im container ist dass du
dann nicht das offizielle home assistant us laufen lassen kannst dann keine
addons hast und auch die abkürzer drüber dann ich machen kann also das finde ich
in dem fall tatsächlich sinnvoll es über den vm laufen zu lassen oder halt
direkt drauf ich meine so 19 euro sin klein kannst du ja mal abstellen für eine
sache das kostet ja nicht die welt
oder gibt sonst noch irgendwas war heute war heute kurz kurz und knackiger stream
ohne wirklich inhalt aber ich habe gar nicht kommen auch nicht war jetzt schon
zwei tage oder so nicht mehr da
warum die machen doch nicht alle gleichzeitig was oder oder hast du 40
wifile kleines die alle gleichzeitig irgendwie großartig bandbreite
verursachen ich meine einfach einfach 40 kleines
connected ist ja nicht das problem bzw 40 kleines mal eingeloggt ist ja nicht
das problem wenn du 40 kleines die ganze zeit am start hast die ganze zeit
senden beziehungsweise traffic verursachen ja dann vielleicht aber
ansonsten juckt das doch die fritzbox nicht
habt ihr tips wenn man sich bei einer it job mehr ist ein paar unternehmen für
physik aus vorstellen will keine ahnung ja gute üblichen sachen wenn du dich
wenn du dich woanders auch bewirbst oder vorstellt ich meine ich würde mir im
vorfeld mal schon angucken wer er so ist um mir vielleicht ein bisschen anschauen
was die so machen falls du falls du auch da irgendwas schon ins auge gefasst
hast ansonsten ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt nicht einfach nur dazu stehen
und sich von denen brieseln zu lassen sondern die auch mal was zu fragen ja
also wie die das was weiß ich was was die für betriebssysteme einsetzen oder
was die welche programmier sprachen sie verwenden auf welcher basis ihre
anwendungen laufen was für was für betriebssystem ob sie linux verwenden
ob sie wenn ausfällt ob sie vielleicht bsd verwenden wir wissen ja wenn sie
kann wenn sie keinen gendt zu selbst kompilieren taugen sie eh nix
es kommt immer gut an wenn du die auf was fragst ich meine so lange nicht
fragst warum seid ihr so kacke oder in der richtung kommt vielleicht nicht gut
an oder wenn du sagst also die typen vom stand vorher haben wir das aber besser
gemacht ansonsten ist glaube ich was nachfragen nicht verkehrt und es werde
hin es werden händering IT IT leute gesucht wie sie in der ausbildung aussieht
weiß ich es nicht ich habe eher das gefühl ausbildungsmäßig ist eher
stagniert aber sie wünschen sich alle mehr
experten wo ich mich immer frage wie soll das eigentlich funktionieren wenn du
nicht ausbildest wo sollen die in die experten herkommen
ja wobei ich sagen wird scheiß auf praktikum versucht lieber gleich mal
eine ausbildungsstelle klar zu machen
genau frag frag ob sie play singly fast sind und wenn sie dich blöd angucken
sagst du kacke laden ihr reitet nix in rust zu euch will ich nicht
ich würde ich würde mir nicht im vorfeld so viele gedanken darüber machen
so nach dem motto ist schwierig findet man wahrscheinlich eh nix das geht wenn
es beidseitig passt so ein bisschen die die chemie auch stimmt man sich da gut
versteht die den guten eindruck von da geht das ganz schnell
ich habe es noch damals bei mir erzählt ich bin damals ein ganzes stück gefahren
zu zu meinem vorstellungsgespräch sachet habe ich ich sage jetzt nicht
wohin aber ich glaube ich habe sogar schon mal geliegt wo das war zu einem
vorstellungsgespräch bin ich ein ganzes stück gefahren und ich habe mir schon im
vorfeld überlegt alda willst du das wirklich machen dahin fahren
das ist ja bis ja fast einen tag unterwegs und wahrscheinlich klappt es
ähnlich und was war am nächsten tag haben sie angerufen haben gesagt hier her
max auf gehts vertrag
das stimmt wohl wobei die sache halti ist viele leute die sich gerade mit
technik beschäftigen die haben halt keinen bock auf die sind nicht die
krassesten socializer und netzwerke ja man also die meisten techniker die ich
kenne es gibt ausnahmen gibt es immer ja ich kenne auch welche die haben zum
beispiel machen die start up geschichten oder war die ganze zeit schon super
kommunikativ die meisten techniker die ich kenne die haben schon einen grund
warum sie techniker beziehungsweise it leute geworden sind das ist hauptsinn
erst mal weil sie keinen bock haben auf andere leute und zum größten halt
abgefuckt sind von anderen leuten ich ja auch ich nehme ich ja da nicht aus
mich mir gehen 95 prozent wahrscheinlich 98 prozent alle anderen menschen einfach
nur auf den sack
das ist das ist ich frage mich mal egal gibt unglaublich viel dumme und
nervige leute aber man kann sich ja schon manchmal ein bisschen zusammen reißen
aber das muss letztendlich ja auch irgendwo passen beidseitig
ja ich verstehe auch nicht genau wie die logik dahinter funktionieren soll
ehrlich gesagt kann es ja nicht sagen ich brauche laufend experten am laufenden
band aber ich will nichts ausbilden was heißt eigentlich experte jemand der die
ausbildung an studium hat oder einfach irgendwas kann für mich ist ein expert
jemand der in einem gebiet halt viel ahnung hat ich habe das absichtlich so
vage gesagt weil ich weil ich da alle in dem fall mit einschließen will und nicht
jedes mal sagen muss ausbildung machen studium hat letztendlich wenn du ahnung
hast wenn du ahnung von einem gefragten thema in der it reißen sich aktuell um
dich wenn du natürlich nur in windows assistent dreimal auf next next ab
abschließend drücken kannst dann selbst dann selbst dann reißen sie sich um
dich
ja der storage experte das war echt einer das habe ich so auch nie wieder
erlebt dass jemand raus eskortiert wurde von der security also ehemaliger
teamleiter von mir als ich noch beim provider gearbeitet habe
der wurde mal bei einem unternehmen für die die dienstleister waren
rausgeschmissen und dann von der security nicht mehr reingelassen also das das
habe ich schon mitgekriegt aber dass jemand wirklich raus eskortiert
worden ist kam bisher nur einmal vor
weißt du noch wie viele bewerber ist bei dem rechtssinnung wenn sie schon
unge- du meinst damals du meinst damals beim provider oder wo die ja die hatten
ach wie viel bewerber nee das weiß ich nicht ich weiß nur dass die quasi fast
halb so viele azubis hatten wie mitarbeiter also wobei ja doch kommt
ungefähr der hatten damals glaube ich irgendwie um die 120 mitarbeiter und 50
davon oder so waren azubis da hat man die azubis wirklich als billige
arbeitskräfte eingestellt aber es war letztendlich nicht verkehrt ganz
ehrlich meine ausbildung war gut und kacke gleichzeitig
sie war kacke weil ich nicht ausgebildet wurde in dem sinn hat sich
keiner um uns gekümmert auf der anderen seite war es gut
man konnte eigentlich machen was man wollte und ist mit hardware und sachen in
berührung gekommen wo man ansonsten nie was mit zu tun hätte
wer hat denn schon mal mit einem IBM mainframe was zu tun ja wer hat mit mit
100.000 euro teuren core switch setups und so was schon was zu tun und und oder
unterschiedliche rechenzentren und alle möglichen sachen das hast du ja
normalerweise nicht die möglichkeit zu aber es hat ja halt keiner wirklich
großartig was erklärt und sich groß um dich gekümmert in der ausbildung ich
habe auf der anderen seite sehr viel gelernt einfach weil ich was gemacht
habe in der ausbildung ab und zu mal die leute genervt hat oder mir vor haupt mir
haupte hier auch sachen angeguckt haben wie das andere leute machen jetzt nicht
so form von max ich zeigte mal was sondern ich habe einfach ich habe den
einfach zu geguckt haben also habe ich viel gelernt in der ausbildung obwohl
die ausbildung selbst richtig kacke war nachnamen lieg fack wurde schon auf das
clean code horrible performance reagiert
nee wo denn stand das hier irgendwie gerade das clean code horrible performance
ok 22 minuten das ist mir jetzt ein bisschen viel moment hat er die
kommentare aus weil die rast die rast task force von hacker news am start war
sieht fast so aus hat er rast nicht genug gelobt das hat hacker news nicht
gefallen ne dat der hat hier auch der hat hier auch die videos öfters mal aus
hätte ich hätte schon gedacht die konnten sich wieder nicht benehmen
nee wir gucken jetzt kein video mehr war jetzt noch kurz den chat durch
du hast adhs und autismus ja gut du kommst mit leuten wahrscheinlich dann
auch nicht so gut klar würde ich jetzt einfach mal so in den raum stellen aber
gibt es in der it ganz viele leute und ich würde auch nicht wundern wenn es
viele autisten gibt in der it die das vielleicht selbst gar nicht wissen
wurde wo sich das nie näher angeguckt wurde
die sich da selbst vielleicht auch gar keine gedanken drüber gemacht haben aber
es ist schon erstaunlich häufig dass ich eben leute die kein bock auf andere
menschen haben in der it tummeln ich meine es hat auch seinen grund warum ich
da gelandet bin letztendlich hat schon seinen grund warum ich das machen
wollte und es hat auch seinen grund warum ich kein first level oder irgendwie
support machen Leute ich habe eine ich habe eine frage an euch ich habe auf
der jetzigen arbeit noch ein kollege mit dem verstehe ich mich ganz gut kann
sogar sein dass das schon mal ein paar stories erzählt
ab wo er dabei gewesen ist er hat in den übelst krassen werde gang der war also
der ist halb halb deutscher halb amy war bei der army oder dort seine it
ausbildung gemacht er war glaube ich falsche springer oder so was hat seine
ausbildung seine it ausbildung in der army gemacht ich glaube bei den falschen
springer ich bin mir da gar nicht so sicher und hat dann irgendwie it bei der
army gemacht ist jetzt wieder zurück nach deutschland von paar jahren und ist
jetzt da so im finanzbranche sektor wo ich auch bin also wie gesagt daher kennen
wir uns ja und der hat früher und immer noch immer noch im also früher hat er
hat er support gemacht so richtig endkunden support und jetzt arbeitet er
bei uns im ich nenne es mal support 24 7 schichtbetrieb und ich habe mir
überlegt ob ich nicht mal mit ihm ein video machen soll so nach dem motto it
support also was verdient man im it support weil er kennt ja bisher immer nur
alles aus meiner sicht ja ihr wisst dass ich der fox engineer bin ihr wisst
ungefähr auch was ich mache und das ist ja nichts neues aber das ist das ist
was ganz anderes schichtbetrieb habe ich keinen plan support so die richtig
hardcore support geschichte mit telefon support von früher heute immer noch
telefon support da mache ich einen riesen riesen riesen bogen drumherum ja ich
kann ihn mal fragen ich finde ich finde es eigentlich nicht schlecht dass man das
war ein bisschen aus anderer sicht was hört also wie viel verdient man dort
also wie viel ist so der kann euch zum beispiel auch erzählen dass sich
schichtarbeiten wirklich lohnen kann weil die haben zwar kein super krasses base
gehalt aber ich weiß dass die doppel und dreifach irgendwie stundenlohn kriegen
teilweise wenn sie wochenend feiertags nacht einsätze haben und sowas das ist
richtig heftig was sie da teilweise kriegen ich glaube 200 prozent ja an
spezieller und dass das auch noch anderweitig versteuert wird das heißt
das base gehalt ist nicht so geil aber unterm strich gibt es trotzdem richtig
viel kohle glaube ich glaube da könnte man was machen der hat auch schon ganz
abgedrehte dinger erzählt ja der hat der hat erzählt dass du du musst ja wohl
auch wenn du in der it bist dort in der army musst du musst du wohl auch so nicht
nur grundausbildung machen sondern du musst auch wirklich einsatzfähig sein
und der hat erzählt die mussten in ihrer ausbildung in so eine wie drücke ich
das jetzt aus das wort ist recht negativ vorbelastet in so eine
drehengaskammer mussten die gehen
und dort glaube ich eine halbe stunde drinnen bleiben mit drehengas und nach ein
paar minuten haben sie den befehl gekriegt sie sollen ihre gasmasken
ausziehen und dann haben die da quasi 20 30 minuten drinnen gesessen ohne gas
masken und haben quasi 20 minuten am stück gekotzt also der hat er hat schon
teilweise echt heftige dinger erzählt
die die amis sind da sind da härter drauf bei der bundeswehr mag das verboten sein
die amis sind da härter drauf die müssen wissen dass das das das das
funktioniert wenn es drauf ankommt ja wobei ich sagen muss
wobei ich sagen muss also wir hatten schon einige leute die bei der bundeswehr
waren und wir hatten auch andere leute die mit militär waren bei anderen
anderen ländern und viele mit vielen der leuten bin ich nicht klar gekommen
die sind nie aus diesem aus diesem militär den im kopf irgendwie raus
gekommen also nach dem motto ich mache ticket nur auf befehlen so nach dem was
war ganz gut viele merkwürdige leute aber bei dem muss ich sagen das ist der
einzige von dem ich zutrauen würde bei uns wenn das gebäude brennt ja als gehen
wir mal von dem fall aus das gebäude brennt und dir fällt eine deckenplatte
auf den kopf bei der flucht aus dem brennenden gebäude der wird umdrehen
würde ich schnappen und rausziehen dass der einzige nämlich das bei uns
zutraue
der kennt da nix richtig richtig giga chat dass der einzige mich das
zutrauen würde der ist eben übelst krass im hart im
nehmen also die ami ausbildung hat da hat da schon hat da schon gemacht so nach
dem ich weiß an einem tag hat er irgendwie ein rollerunfall ist er mit
seinem roller ist ihm einer mit dem auto hinten drauf gebrummt mit dem roller
er ist irgendwie zwei meter durch die luft geflogen war bewusstlos
krankenwagen kam alles mögliche und ratet mal während ein tag später schon
wieder auf der arbeit gehockt hat
so nach dem motto nach krankenhaus gehirnerschütterung scheiß drauf ich
gehe jetzt auf die arbeit also bei dem hat die armee ausbildung und schon
dafür geht zu geführt dass er recht hart im nehmen ist
wieso nicht am selben tag ja klar ich bin so weit hinten dran im chat ich
gebe das jetzt einfach mal alles und zwar glaube ich sogar ich glaube ich
glaube das war sogar nach einem arbeitstag wo er heim gefahren ist mit
dem roller also ich rede nicht von so einem elektro roller sondern sondern
von einem normalen das was man bis vor ein paar jahren unter roller
verstanden hat halt so ein so ein kein motorrad halt in roller so mit motor
tritt und so was
ein roller halt so auf zwei rede und so was zum zum fahren kein mofa ja ja auf
hier kann ich mal fragen ob wir da nicht ein video aufnehmen wollen
da mache ich quasi ein eigenes lohnt sich das format bei mir auf dem channel
könnte man echt machen ich meine ich kenne auch genug leute mit denen ich
tatsächlich also das klingt jetzt wahnsinnig viel und ich habe gerade
gesagt ich komme nicht gut mit leuten klar wenn ich sage ich kenne genug leute
ich kenne bestimmt noch fünf leute oder so mit denen ich tatsächlich was
aufnehmen könnte in der richtung auch alle auch ein bisschen aus
unterschiedlichen gebieten
also man könnte theoretisch sogar könnte sogar einen projekt manager fragen wenn
man man das will ne will ich eigentlich nicht ja das will ich auf jeden fall
auch machen das kann man nicht einfach nur eine halbe stunde labern irgendwas
random ich fragte einfach mal wissen was mit dem
gehe ich öfters in frankfurt auch mal zu mexikaner futtern mittags das stellen
das nächste mal einfach ein handy auf und nehmen was auf mal deinen chef aber
mit dir ein video macht mein chef der hat mit youtube nix am hut aber ich
könnte meinen ex chef fragen der kannte ja sogar meinen channel und hat der war
hier sogar manchmal schon im chat mein ex chef ich habe nur nie was gesagt weil
ich nicht wollte dass er liegt wird ja leute so sieht es aus
naja das wäre theoretisch möglich ja chain law
ne chain law ist es nicht chain law ich kann mir den chain law nicht als chef
vorstellen ehrlich gesagt
wie soll das ausgehen wie soll das aussehen das erste was passiert ist
dein chef wird erst mal discord bunt oder erst chat wird er dein chef wird
erst mal aus dem channel gebannt das kann es ja nicht sein
ok leute ich gehe jetzt pennen wir sehen uns morgen macht's gut oder die
tage dann bis dann macht's gut zu